İyi akşamlar arkadaşlar, 18 Kasım 2024 Pazartesi günü 40. ders günümüz saat 19.31 dersimize başlıyoruz.
Kaldığımız yerden devam edeceğiz, ses ya da görüntüde problem olursa bildirin lütfen değerli arkadaşlar.
Geçen dersimizin sonunda iteratörlerle ilgili işlemler yapan, iteratörleri manipüle eden fonksiyonları gördük.
STL'de neydi bunlar?
Bu fonksiyonlar stud-advance, stud-distance, iter-swap, next ve prev fonksiyonlarıydı.
STL algoritmalarının implementasyonda da tipik olarak zaten bu neler kullanılıyor arkadaşlar?
Fonksiyonlar kullanılıyor.
Bu fonksiyonların hemen hepsi bazı jenerik programlama teknikleriyle iteratörün kategorisini elde ederek o iteratör kategorisine göre kod seçimi de sağlıyor idi.
Şimdi başka neler gördük?
İteratör adaptörlerini gördük çoğunu.
Reverse iteratör, const reverse iteratör, const iteratör, post-stream iteratör değil mi?
Efendim back-insert iteratör, front-insert iteratör, insert iteratör ve bunları veren back-inserter, front-inserter ve inserter fonksiyonlarını gördük.
Biraz daha algoritmalardan ve iteratörlerden bahsedeceğim.
Ondan sonra belirli bir sırayla biraz da tempoyu yükselterek STL konteynerlarını detaylı olarak inceleyeceğiz.
Ama önce biraz algoritma tarafına bakalım.
Arkadaşlar, bir range üstünde işlem yapan, range'i değiştiren range'e yazan algoritmalar var dedik.
Bunlardan copy algoritmasını gördük.
Ama copy ile ilgili bir de copy-if algoritması vardı değil mi?
Copy-if algoritması ne yapıyor?
Bir unary predikatın true değer döndürdüğü öğeleri kopyalıyor.
Zaten algoritmaların bir kısmında böyle bir isimlendirme notasyonu var.
Arkadaşlar, mesela copy, copy-if, count, count-if.
Sonra if ile bitenler, if ile bitmeyenlere göre arkadaşlar belirli bir koşul sağlandığı zaman o işi yapıyorlar.
Yani bir redikat istiyorlar.
Mesela replace, replace-if, replace-copy, replace-copy-if gibi.
Copy algoritmalarından bir tane daha var.
Eski C++4'da yoktu.
C++11 standartıyla dile eklendi.
Normalde copy, hatırlıyorsunuz en çok kullandığımız algoritmalardan biri.
Bir iteratör range alıyor kaynak olarak.
Bir de hedef range'in başlangıcını alıyor.
Kaynak olarak aldığı range'deki öğeleri hedef range'e yazıyor.
Bütün yazma algoritmaları zaten en son yazılan konumdan sonraki konumu döndürüyorlar idi.
Arkadaşlar, oysa copy-an algoritması adı da üstünde en tane öğeyi kopyalıyor.
Mesela vektörün, isterseniz şöyle yazalım.
Şimdilik using bildirimini yapalım.
Ve neutrity başlık dosyamızı da ekleyelim.
Vektörün string açılımı.
Biraz daha eğlenceli olsun örneğimiz.
Aspect random fill.
Aspect r name.
Ya da neutrity random name.
Evet.
İkinci parametreye de örneğin 20 değerini geçelim.
Şimdi elimizde bir de liste konteynerı olsun.
Arkadaşlar, listin string açılımı s-list.
Şimdi bakınız.
Copy algoritmasında eğer çağırıyor olsaydım, geçen derste bir hatırlatmış oluruz.
Aspect begin, aspect end, eğer listedeki öğelerin üstüne yazmak isteseydim, şu anda liste boş, liste de en az kaynak range'deki kadar öğe olmalıydı.
Ama istersem sonu ekleme çağrısına dönüştürmesi için örneğin backinsurter fonksiyonunu kullanabilirim.
Backinsurter s-list.
Eğer listede öğe olsaydı, örneğin listede 100 tane öğe olsaydı, doğrudan s-listin beginini argüman olarak verseydim,
yazılmış öğelerin el konumu için copy'nin geri dönüşte yeri olan iteratör konumunu kullanabilirdim.
Ama bir de şimdi copy n'e bakalım.
Copy n'e arkadaşlar, birinci parametresi kaynak range'in başlangıcı, ikinci parametresi kaç tane öğe kopyalanacağı, zaten o yüzden ismi copy'nin.
Üçüncü parametre arkadaşlar yine hedef range.
Yani bu sefer şöyle kullanıyoruz, s-back-begin, örneğin hepsini yazacaksam s-back-size, nereden itibaren örneğin s-list-begin.
Yine geri dönüş değeri en son yazdığı öğeden sonraki konu.
Ama isteseydim, son ekleme y'de dönüştürebilirdim.
Yine aslında bu herhangi bir algoritma için geçerli değil mi?
Buraya yaz demek yerine,
back-insorter, front-insorter ya da insorter fonksiyonlarından birini çağırarak,
doğrudan bu adaptörü kullanarak listeye, sondan eklemeye dönüştürebilirdik.
Ya da parçtan eklemeye.
Arkadaşlar, bir de copy-back-ward fonksiyonu var.
Bakın, kopyalama ile ilgili fonksiyonlar.
Hadi hepsini şöyle hızlıca bir görelim.
copy, copy-and, copy-if, copy-if'i de bir hatırlayalım.
Mesela, vektördeki öğeler 100 tane olsun.
Yine bir başka vektör nesnemiz olsun.
Pekala, başka bir konteyner de olabilir.
Vektörün string açılımı, best-vec, size t len, arkadaşlar, cout, uzunluğu kaç olanlar kopyalansın?
Be in len, copy-if, s-vec-begin, s-vec-end.
Üçüncü parametre, s-vec, yine örneğin backinsurter'ı kullanabilirim.
Ya da üstünü yazabilirim.
Şu anda konteynerim boş.
Desk-vec.
Bunları predikat olarak bir lambda ifadesi kullanayım.
Len'i capture edeyim.
const struct string, ref s, return s len, eşit eşit len.
Artık lambda ifadelerini de kullanmayı epey bir inceledik.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi artık listede sadece uzunluğu bu değerde olanlar var.
Listeyi de yazdırmak için, bu sefer de copy algoritmasını kullanalım.
Copy.
Evet, evet, notability defonksiyonum var ama o stream iterator sınıfını da bir hatırlatmak istiyorum.
S-list begin, s-list end, is in, o stream iteratorun, string açılımı, siyah separatör olarak da boşluk verdim.
S-list değilmiş yalnız ismi, bestback'miş.
Onu da düzeltelim.
Bestback, bestback, süper.
Noktalı virgülümüzü koyalım, terminator token'ımızı.
Evet, vektörün kendisini yazdırmıyorum.
Evet, uzunluğu kaç olanlar kopyalansın?
Yedi, Mecmiye, Teslime, Kayhan, Emirhan, Aslıhan, Feramus, uzunluğu katı olanlar kopyalansın.
Dokuz, sadece Alparslan ve beş.
Güzel, kopya da kopya da kopya da bir örnek vermiş olduk.
Arkadaşlar, şimdi overlap range der söz konusu olduğu zaman kopyalamanın yönünün ne olduğuna bağlı olarak farklı algoritma seçmek gerekiyor değil mi?
Yani şöyle bir durum olsun örneğin.
Arkadaşlar, iki, beş, yedi, dokuz, üç.
Takip edebiliyor muyuz?
Evet.
Şimdi ben bu range'i programcı tabiriyle kaydırmak istesem, arkadaşlar, kopyalamaya buradan başlasam, örneğin bir kaydırmak istesem, yani bu range'i buraya kopyalamak istesem, o zaman önce ikinin yerine ikiyi yazmış olurum.
E zaten kaynak da değişmiş olurum.
Eğer kopyalama sol tarafa doğru yapılsaydı, bu tür overlapping de bir problem olmayacaktı.
O yüzden copy ile birlikte bir de copy backward isimli bir fonksiyon var.
Arkadaşlar, copy backward.
Yani geriye doğru kopyalama.
Copy backward şunu yapıyor.
Örneğin, iki, üç, beş, yedi, dokuz.
Arkadaşlar, kopyalamayı yaptığınız alt konumunu veriyorsunuz.
Orası yeni alt konumu olacak.
Ve kopyalamayı şöyle yapıyor.
Dokuz, yedi, beş, üç, iki.
Böylece o rack blokları güvenli bir şekilde kopyalamış oluyorsunuz.
Hadi öyle bir örnek verelim.
Copy backward'ı da gösterelim.
Bir tane vektörümüz olsun.
Vektör.
Arkadaşlar, int açılımı.
Evek.
Efendim, bir, üç, beş, yedi, dokuz.
Bakın, burada mesela beş tane vek var.
Vektörün başka bir konteyner de olabilirdi.
Int açılımı.
BestVec.
Burada da, arkadaşlar, dokuz tane vek olsun ya da yedi tane vek olsun.
Bir şeye dikkat edin.
Bu konteyner, BestVec'i yedi tane sıfır değeriyle dolduruyor.
Hatta bunu göstermek için önce BestVec'i de yazdıralım.
Jprint.
BestVec.
Şimdi, copy, backwards.
Birinci, ikinci parametreler.
Arkadaşlar, kaynak.
Evet.
Efendim, Evek Begin.
Evek End.
Fakat üçüncü parametreyi izleyin.
DestVec.
Endi argüman olarak geçiyorum.
Ve
Jprint.
DestVec.
Evet, görüyorsunuz arkadaşlar.
Bir, üç, beş, yedi, dokuzu benim söylediğim biçimde ne yapmış oldu?
Kopyalamış oldu.
Şimdi, biraz şaşırtıcı bir örnek olacak ama kopyalamayla ilgili şunları konuşmuş olduk.
Neredeydi?
Evet, bir daha yazalım.
Copy.
Copy if.
Copy and.
Ve bir de arkadaşlar, ne dedik?
Copy backward.
Hemen araya bir tane daha ekleyelim.
Arkadaşlar, bir tane algoritma var.
Bakın, biri reverse, diğeri reverse copy.
Şimdi, reverse algoritması, birinci reverse ediyor.
Bunu tahmin etmek zor değil.
Yani, ters yüz ediyor.
Reverse copy ise,
range'in kendisine değil,
ters çevrilmiş halini bir yere kopyalıyor.
Yani, range'in kendisi üstünde bir işlem yapmıyor.
Önce bir reverse'ü gösterelim.
Bu da en sık kullanılan algoritmalardan biri.
Arkadaşlar, rektörün...
İVEC.
Bu sefer doğrudan...
İlk değer vereyim.
İki, üç, altı, yedi, sekiz, bir, dokuz, beş, sıfır, dört.
List olsun bir tane de.
Ama burada bir uyarı yapacağım.
List, stoblist'in...
Arkadaşlar, int açılımı, ilist.
Açıklamayı biraz yapayım.
Birazdan yapayım.
Stobstring.
Arkadaşlar, string'in de bir stl konteynerı olduğunu unutmayalım.
Bu yüzden string'in interpeşisinde, örneğin reverse isimli bir fonksiyon yok.
Çünkü bu da bir konteyner.
Reverse algoritmasını kullanabilirim.
Name.
Emre türsever.
Arkadaşlarımdan birinin ismi.
Şimdi buraya...
Bu arada araya lambda ifadelerini de karıştıralım.
Monstoto.
Print.
Eşittir.
İlk lambda fonksiyonu da 10 denir yazdırmak için kullanabilirim.
Değil mi?
İlal behaves.
INK.
İlalпер.
İlal boyfriend.
put fonksiyonunu çağırıyorum.
Evet buraya kadar bir
print fonksiyonuna
önce
ibeki argüman olarak gönderelim.
Şuradaki c'yi
e yapalım.
Derleyelim.
Evet bir problem yok.
Şimdi algoritm başlık dosyasındaki
reverse'ü çağırıyorum.
Reverse
Minimum
Bidirectional ikalatör istiyor.
ibeki begin
ibeki end
Reverse ettikten sonra tekrar yazdırıyorum.
Arkadaşlar
normalde liste için
reverse fonksiyonunu çağırmazdım.
Çünkü listin kendi reverse fonksiyonu var.
Bunu list
konteynerına geldiğimizde konuşacağız.
Ama şimdi
Bidirectional'lı iteratör olduğunu göstermek için
buraya tercih etmezdim
uyarısını koyayım.
ve
print
ilist
jprint
print
ilist
iki tane i varmış o yüzden altını çiziyor.
şuradan
kopyalama yapalım.
ve
print
bu da bir konteyner
özellikle onu vurgulamak için print'i çağırıyorum.
neydi ismi
name
reverse
name begin
name end
string'in bir konteyner olmasından çok faydalanıyoruz
üretimde.
evet
bakın
emretür severi yazısını
ters çevirdi değil mi?
aslında arada boşluk yok.
ben yazılırken boşluk karakteri vermiş oldum.
güzel
şimdi bir de
reverse kopya bakalım.
elimizde zaten bir vektör var.
bir de
liste olsun
ya da
dek olsun bu sefer.
diğer konteynerı da
yavaş yavaş
isimlerini
telhafiz etmeye
başlayalım.
aynı sayıda
V'ye sahip
arkadaşlar
ve şimdi bakın
reverse copy
kaynak
ibek begin
ibek end
dq
begin
j print
ibek
arkadaşlar
dq
evet gördüğünüz gibi
range'in kendisini değil
tersini
kopyaladı.
o da gayet faydalı bir
algoritma.
böylece
bir de
replace copy
fonksiyonumuz oldu
arkadaşlar.
reverse copy
fonksiyonumuz oldu.
hemen hızlı bir şekilde
diğer kopyalamalara da bakalım
biraz hızlanalım.
arkadaşlar çok güzel.
STL algoritmaları
birkaç tanesi haricinde
son derece basit
kolay anlaşılır.
ve günlük yazdığımız kodlarda
sık sık
kullandığımız varlıklar.
zaten kötü kodların en tipik
belirtilerinden biri de
STL algoritmasını
kullanmak yerine
ham döngü kodu yazmak.
rawlu.
meşhur
ilkemiz neydi?
avoid
rawlu.
ham döngülerden
kaçının.
şimdi bir de
şuna bakalım.
bakın
stud replace
bunları hızlı geçeceğim.
oradan şu
bildirim üstünden
anlatacağım.
evet
replace
replace'in ne olduğunu
biliyoruz değil mi?
bir şeyin yerine
başka bir şey koymak.
bakın şimdi
birincisi
on derece basit.
bir ence
veriyorsanız
arkadaşlar
eski değeri
veriyorsunuz.
onun yerine
geçecek
yeni değeri
veriyorsunuz.
hemen bir örnek
yapalım mı?
geri dönüş
değeri yok.
mesela
yine vektör
üstünde bir
örnek yapalım.
arkadaşlar
vektörün
int açılımı
ibec
random fill
50 tane
ayrı
arkadaşlar
5 aralığında
değer
c
print
ibec
buraya kadar
değerli edeyim.
rastgele
0 5 aralığı
değerlerle doldurduğumu
görüyorsunuz.
ama şimdi bakın
replace
range'i veriyorum
ibec
begin
and
arkadaşlar
eski değeri
veriyorum
örneğin
yeni değeri
veriyorum
bunlar
sabit
ifadesi
olmak zorunda
değil değil mi?
örneğin
ne olsun
eksi 1
böylece
3'lerin yerine
eksi 1
yazmış olacak
olabilecek
en basit
algoritmalardan biri.
algoritmalar
çok karmaşık olduğu için
var değil
niyeti
iyi anlattığı için
var.
yoksa
şunun template
kodunu
bir dakikada
siz de yazarsınız
değil mi?
tekrar
print ediyorum
range'i
3'lerin yerinde
eksi 1
olduğunu
görüyorsunuz.
Peki
replace if
ne yapıyor?
de
bir koşulu
sağlayanları
belirli bir değerle
değiştiriyor.
Mesela
şimdi
bu sefer
konteynerdaki
öğeleri
değiştirelim
aralığında
olsun
ve
diyelim ki
bir tane de
yine
input alalım
see out
kaça bölünenler
Türkçe yazıyorum
ama promptu
kaça bölünenler
see in
n
hatta
int by
see out
yeni değer
see in
var
şimdi bakın
replace if
birinci
ikinci
parametre
yine
range
ibek
begin
end
üçüncü parametre
unary
predicate
capture
n
int
e
return
mod
n
eşit eşit
böylece
n'e tam
olarak
bölünenlerin
yerine
yeni
değer olarak
vali
yazsın
gerçekten
işini
doğru
yaptığını
göstermek
için
bir
debug edelim
evet
kaça bölünenler
efendim
üçe bölünenlerin
yerine
yeni
değer olarak
ne yaz
sıfır
hatta olmayan
bir değer
eksi bir yaz
evet bakın
üçe bölündüğü için
eksi bir geldi
vesaire
üçe bölünenlerin
yerine
daha da kolay
anlaşılsın diye
beşe bölünenlerin
yerine
arkadaşlar
sıfır
koysun
yoksa
bir
koysun
kaç
bölünenler
beş
yeni
değer
bir
evet
ve ondan sonra
böyle gidiyor
replace
ve
son derece
basit
algoritmalar
replace
copy
diğer örneklerde
olduğu gibi
işlemi
rengin
üstünde
yapmak
yerine
yapılmış
biçimini
bir yere
kopyalıyor
ne demek bu
örneğin
yine böyle
bir
vektörümüz
olsun
şuraya
kadar
aynısı
arkadaşlar
elimde
bir
vektör
daha
olsun
vektörün
int açılımı
devek
yeteri kadar
büyük olsun
evekin
size
herhalde
tahmin etmeniz
zor değil
replace
copy
birinci
ikinci parametre
kaynak range
üçüncü parametre
hedef range
dördüncü ve beşinci
parametre
old value
new value
yani
şöyle çağıracağız
ibek
begin
end
arkadaşlar
bebek
begin
değerleri de
biraz küçültelim ki
daha iyi
görülsün
arkadaşlar
örneğin
yedi
ikilerin yerine
dokuz
soru
ibek üstünde
bir değişiklik
yaptı mı
hayır
sanki
ibek'i deveke
kopyalasaydık
aynen kopyalanacak da
şimdi sıfırlar
yerine
yediği
kopyalayacak
ama sıfır dışındaki
değerlerin yine
kendisi
kopyalanmış
olacak
jebring
devek
biraz da
peki böyle kalsın
evet
arkadaşlar
gördüğünüz gibi
sıfır yerine
aynısını
yazdırdık
ibek
begin
end
devek
begin
iki
ikinin yerine
dokuzmuş
sıfır
evet
burada iki var
dokuz
iki var dokuz
iki var
dokuz
ama iki dışındakileri
değiştirmedi
replace
kopyalı
bu da var
bunu da artık
ne yaptığını
tahmin edebilirsiniz
replace
kopyalı
devek
begin
arkadaşlar
şuraya kadar
bildirime
bakın
replace
kopyalı
bir dakika
replace
kopyalı
ne alaka
replace
kopyalı
yok
replace
kopyalı
var
reverse
kopyalı
var
ripte
riptes
kopyalı
var
niye
olmaz
benimle
şaşırtmanız
suçu
sizde
buluyorum
arkadaşlar
replace
kopyalı
son derece
basit
yine
aynı
mantık
bu
range
teki
öğeleri
bakın
bu range
teki
öğeleri
buraya
kopyalayacak
ama
bu
predikete
true
bu predikatın
değer verdiğini
bu değerle
değiştirerek
kopyalayacak
mesela
şurayı yine
değiştirelim
arkadaşlar
bu sefer
uzatmayacağım
çift sayıların yerine
eksi 1
kopyalayacağım
o zaman
rickleskopi
if
ben de şaşırdım
olabildim
rickleskopi
if
evekbegin
evekent
üçüncü parametre
devekbegin
dördüncü parametre
unerif
prediket
int x
return
x
mod
3'e bölünen
eşit
ve son parametrede
10 yerine
ne kopyalanacak
evet
hatta şöyle
yapalım da
arkadaşlar
tek basamaklı
olsun
daha kolay olsun
3'e tam
bölünenlerin
yerine
eksi 1
kopyalayacak
jprint
evet
terbiyorum
bakın
6'nın yerine
eksi 1
yine
0'ın yerine
eksi 1
3'ün yerine
şimdi bir
algoritma grubunu
daha anlatacağım
ondan sonra
artık
konteynerlara
geçeceğiz
arkadaşlar
şimdi
size bir soru
algoritma
herhangi bir
bir
range'e
alıp
sadece
bir range'e
alıp
o range'in
sahibi olan
konteynera
ekleme
işlemi
yapabilir
cevap
hayır
arkadaşlar
algoritmalar
iteratör
parametresine
sahip
yani örneğin
şöyle bir şey
yapabilir miyiz
template
type name
iter
boyut
algo
iter
back
and
şimdi
bu algoritma
ismine
algo
dediğim
algoritma
öyle bir
işlem
yapsın ki
bu range'teki
öğelerin
sayısını
arttırsın
yani bu range'te
10 tane öğe
varken
12 tane öğe
olsun
bunu yapma
yapabilme
ihtimali var mı
yok
neden
çünkü
ekleme yapmak için
konteyner nesnesinin
kendisine
ihtiyacımız var
ancak bir
konteynerı
o da
referans
semantiğiyle
alan bir
fonksiyon
o konteynerın
ekleme
fonksiyonunu
çarabilir
aynı şey
silme işlemleri
için de
geçerli
bir
algoritma
bir range'ten
öğe
silemez
yani örneğin
ben size
deseydim ki
ismi
xyz
remove
olan bir
fonksiyon var
bu fonksiyona
siz bir range'i
göndereceksiniz
bu range'teki
örneğin
belirli
koşulu
sağlayan
öğeler
silinecek
hemen ne
demelisiniz
olmaz
bize
bunu
yutturamazsın
çünkü
konteynerden
yine silme işlemi
yapabilmek için
konteyner nesnesinin
kendisine
ihtiyacımız var
konteyner nesnesinin
kendisi olmadan
sadece
iteratör konumuyla
silme işlemi
yapamayız
desek de
STL'de
silme algoritmaları
diyebileceğimiz
remove
algoritmaları
var
İngilizce
biliyorsunuz
remove
fiil hali
removal
isim hali
bunlar
remove
if
ve
unique
fonksiyonları
şimdi ilk defa
tanışanların
biraz kafası
karışıyor
özellikle ben
ilk defa
bu algoritmaları
büyüyecek
arkadaşlar için
konuşuyorum
bilen arkadaşlarım
tabi var
çok
arkadaşlar
nasıl olacak da
remove isimli bir algoritma
bir inçten
üye silecek
nasıl olacak da
remove if
isimli algoritma
bir inçten
belirli koşulu
sağlayanları
silecek
unique
algoritmasını
daha önce duymamış
olabilirsiniz
yani
C++'dan
bahsetmiyorum
bu algoritmanın
ismi hangi
programlama dili olursa olsun
bu algoritma
ve ihtiyaç
arkadaşlar
unique
ne demek
önce ondan da
bahsedelim
unique
ingilizce kelime
anlamından
bahsetmiyorum
şüphesiz
pek eşsiz
demek
ardışık
eşdeğer
öğelerin
sayısını
bire indiriyor
yani örneğin
şöyle bir
range olduğunu
düşünelim
arkadaşlar
bu range
üstünde
equal'u kullanarak
eşitlik
karşılaştırmasını
kullanarak
unique yaparsanız
range'i ne hale getirmiş
olacaksınız
beraber yapan
üç
öncekiyle aynı
uçur
yani
sil anlamında
uçur
ve
işte range'i
unique hale
getirdim
arkadaşlar
eğer
önce range'i sıralayıp
sonra unique hale
getirirseniz
ne hale getirmiş
olursunuz
her değerden
bir tane
kalır
anlaşıldı
değil mi
şimdi ben bunu
önce sıradasaydım
sonra unique
hale getirseydim
her değerden
bir tane
kalırdı
şimdi unique'in ne olduğunu
anlattık
remove'u anlatmaya
gerek yok
belirli bir değeri
silecek
remove'i
belirli koşulu
sağlayanları
silecek
iyi de
nasıl
iteratör alıp
silecek
en basit
remove'dan
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
diyelim ki
bizim
range'imiz var
tabi
gösterim kolaylığı
olsun diye
ben
tek tam sayılar
üstünde
gösteriyorum
daha çok
oysa
binlerce
on binlerce
farklı
konteyner'ın
farklı range
olabilir
string'ler
fighter'lar
olabilir
date'ler
değil mi
evet
diyelim ki
burada
remove algoritmasıyla
ben
ikileri
silmek istiyorum
o zaman
remove'u şöyle
çağırıyorum
st
remove
işte
diyelim ki
konteyner'ın
ismi c
c
begin
konteyner'ın
end'i
ve silincek
değer
silme imkanı
yok
arkadaşlar
lojik silme
dediğimiz
operasyonu
uyguluyor
lojik silme
şu demek
range'i öyle
bir hale getirecek
ki
bakın 8
2 silinmiş
olması gerekir
değil mi
atladım
bir daha
2 var
o da silindi
bir 2 daha
var
o da silindi
bir 2 daha
var
o da silindi
bir 2 daha
var
o da silindi
bir 2 daha
var
o da silindi
range'i
bu hale getiriyor
buraya dikkat
ve
geri dönüş
değeri olarak
size
arkadaşlar
sözde
silinmemiş
öğelerin
aslında gerçek silme
yok
end konumunu
veriyor
ben buna
lojik
end konumu
diyorum
böylece
arkadaşlar
izleyin
böylece
siz
remove
fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
şu olanaklara
sahip
oluyorsunuz
a
gerçekten
silme işlemi
yapmam
yani
konteynerın
size'ını
değiştirmem
madem
bana
silinmemişler
gerekiyor
o zaman
bu range'i
sanki
öğeler
silinmiş
gibi
silinseydi
çıkacak
öğeler
konteynerden
çıkmış gibi
ama aslında
çıkmadı
kullanırım
şu
yıldız yerine
koyduğum
aslında
silme
algoritmasının
bana
döndürdüğü
geri dönüş
değeri
ama bir
olanak
daha var
o da şu
daha önce de
konuştuğumuz gibi
konteynerların
arkadaşlar
bir
range alan
yani bir
iteratör
çifte alan
silme
fonksiyonları
var
mesela
ben
şu range'i
verseydim
silme
fonksiyonuna
5'i
end
konumu
olarak
verseydim
8'i
4'ü
7'i
silecekti
o zaman
silme
algoritmasının
geri dönüş
değerini
range'in
begin
konumu
olarak
versen
konteynerın
gerçek
end
konumunu
konumu
olarak
verip
bu iki
iteratörle
konteynerın
silme
fonksiyonunu
çağırsam
arkadaşlar
ne olacak
bu durumda
bu öğeleri
fiilen
silecek
o yüzden
silme
algoritmaları
çok efektif
yani
adeta
diyorlar ki
ister kardeşim
sadece
beni çağır
lojik
silmeyle
idare et
istersen de
daha sonra
konteynerın
range
parametreli
erase
fonksiyonunu
çağır
silmeyi
fiilen
gerçekleştir
hadi bakalım
örnek verelim
arkadaşlar
burada bana
en çok sorulan
soru şu
ki
sorunun cevabı
hayır
Necati
senin verdiğin
örnekte
ben şu
konumu
dolaşsam
bu konumdaki
öğeler
iki olmak
zorunda mı
senin örneğinde
cevap
hayır
böyle bir
garanti yok
kaldı ki
bu
buradaki
öğeler
taşınmış
durumda
da olabilir
yani
buradaki
öğeleri
a
ya hiç
dolaşmayın
b
dolaşırsanız
bunların
değerinin
silinen
değer olarak
halen
durduğunu
düşünmeyin
ve son
olarak
arkadaşlar
eğer bu
konteynerda
tutulan
öğeler
kaynağı
çalınabilecek
öğelerse
bu
algoritma
taşıma
semantiğinden
de faydalandığı
için onlar
taşınmış
durumda
yani
moved
from state
de
olabilir
peki
Necati
buraya
ulaşıp
buradaki
öğelere
başka değer
yok
diyebilir
miyim
hayır
onda
hiçbir
sakınca
yok
hadi
bakalım
basit bir örnekle
başlayalım
arkadaşlar
vektörün
yine
int açılımı
vek
random fill
ya da
ayrent
c
print
vek
yani
arası
40 tane
değerle
doldurup
yazdırdım
şimdi
bakınız
arkadaşlar
remove
buraya
bundan
sonrasında
dikkat
vek
begin
vek end
hatta
diğeri de dışarıdan
olalım
int
i
see out
enter
the value
to
remove
see in
i
remove
vek begin
vek end
i
şimdi buraya
dikkat
ben
remove'un
geri dönüş
değerini
size de
gösterebilmek
için
arkadaşlar
logic
end
iter
ismini
veriyorum
evet uzun bir isim ama
konuyu anlattığı için
evet
arkadaşlar
çünkü
logic end
konumunu
öndürüyor
şimdi sırasıyla
bakın
bir
arkadaşlar
ben
container'ın
begini ve logic
end
iter'i
range olarak
kullanıp
o range
teki
öğeleri
basit bir
fonksiyonla
yazdırabilirim
örneğin
jprint
vek begin
anlamadığınız
en fark
yeri olursa
lütfen
söyleyin
logic
end
iter
izleyin
enter
the value
to remove
birler
gitsin
abi
bakın
arkadaşlar
burada
hiçbiri yok
5 6 7 5
bu birler
gitti
bu bir
değil mi
asla gitti
dediğim
container'ın
sayesinde
bir değişme
olmadı
ama
onu da
göstermek
istiyorum
silme
işlemi
yapmadan
önce
see out
sayes
eşittir
zaten
mümkün
değil ama
yine de göstermekte
fayda var
vek size
silme
işleminden
sonra
sözde silme
işleminden
sonra
size
değişmedi
efendim
5'ler
silinsin
size
sadece
silinmemiş
öğelerin
rencini
dolaştım
ama
eğer ben
silinmemiş
öğelerin
sayısını
bulmak
isteseydim
silinmemiş
derin
geçen
derste
öğrendiğimiz
distance
fonksiyonunu
çağırır
wake
begin
ve
logic
antiterli
arkadaşlar
buradaki
v sayısını
bulabilirdim
see out
evet
number
of
arkadaşlar
ne diyelim
unraised
öyle bir terim yok ama
elems
ya da
remaining
sözde
elems
evet
diğer
distance'ı
kullanarak
arkadaşlar
izleyin
number
of
arrays
denem
o da
tahmin edebileceğiniz
gibi
logic
antiter
bu sefer
wake
end
enter
the value
to remove
size
değişmedi
silinmemiş
öğe sayısı
silinmiş
ama şunu da
göstermek istiyorum
şu tipik yanlış
anlamayı
cprint
range
print
eden
fonksiyonuma
arkadaşlar
logic
antiter
wake
end
range
ni
argüman
olarak
veriyorum
ve
burada
iki değerlerinin
silinecek
değer karşısında
olmasını
beklemeyin
diyorum
öyle bir garanti
yok
örneğin
arkadaşlar
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
burada
8'ler
yok
bunu
yorum satırına
alalım
şimdi
gerçek silme
işlemini
yapalım
gerçek silme
işlemi
için
see out
alms
are
being
erased
ama
nasıl
sileceğim
container
container'ın
vec
erase
fonksiyonunu
çağıracağım
container'ın
erase
fonksiyonuna
işte
bu
range'i
argüman
olarak
geçtiğimde
bu
range
silinmiş
olacak
ve
şimdi
tekrar
size'ı
yazdırdığımda
size'ın
gerçekten
azaldığını
göreceksiniz
soru varmış
uzun süredir
bakmadım
emirhan
çelik diyor ki
dangling
hayır
değil
ne zaman
soruyu
sordunuz
onu
kaçırdım
emirhan ama
eğer şunu
soruyorsanız
burada bir
tanımsız
davranış
var mı
hayır
dangling
değil
sadece şunu
söyledim
emirhan
orada
o
silinen
değerlerin
olma
garantisi
yok
cengizhan
diyor ki
son atajı
evet
orada
sıvap
işlemleriyle
son atajı
algoritmaya
bakabilirsiniz
kendinizi de
implemente
edebilirsiniz
enter the value
to remove
sıfır
arkadaşlar
iki tane
sadece silinmiş
ve
böyleler
gerçekten siliniyor
size
olmuş
biraz
aralığı
daraltalım
bir kez daha
çalıştıralım
evet
üçleri
silsin
evet
üçleri
sildi
number of
remaining
elements
burada
6 tane
öğe silinmiş
gerçekten
öğeleri
sildim
şimdi burada
tüm zamanların
en azından
C++
öncesi
arkadaşlar
en çok
sorulan
mülakat sorularından
biri
tüm
yüzyıl
yapıydı
artık
benim bir
arkadaşımın
şöyle bir
sözü vardı
biliyor musun
diye
sorduklarında
bilmeyeni
dövüyorlar
zaten
cengiz anın
dediği gibi
erase
remove
gidiyor
eğer
amacım
sadece
o değerleri
konteynerden
çıkartmaksa
arkadaşlar
eğer amacım
sadece
o değerleri
konteynerden
çıkartmaksa
bu
demin geri dönüş
değerini
değişken
tutmak
vesaire
bunlarla
hiç
ilgilenmeden
önce
arkadaşlar
remove'u
çağırıp
remove
wegbegin
wegend
efendim
i
e madem
bu
logic
end
konumu
döndürüyor
şimdi de
erase'i
çağırıyorum
o yüzden
erase
remove
da diyorlar
erase
diyorlar
yani
yazım
soldan
sağa
okursanız
erase
remove
ama
gerçekten
fonksiyonların
çağrılma
sırasına
bakarsanız
cengiz an
belediği gibi
remove
erase
bu durum
evet
nedir
arkadaşlar
weg
end
ve gerçekten
container'ı
yazdırıyoruz
ve size'ını da
fiyat
size eşittir
waken size'ı
fiyatlar
silinsin
size
ama sonra
c++
20 ve sonrasında
ne yaptılar
ayağın
daha da
sadeleştirdiler
arkadaşlar
bir şey
idiomsa
herkes aynı
idiomu yazıyorsa
o zaman
idiomu yazdırırım
niye ben
yazayım
gerçekten de
bu mantıkla
global erase
fonksiyonu
koydular
yani
şimdi artık
erase
limo
idiomunu
kullanmanıza da
gerçekten
gerek yok
neden
e
çünkü
global erase
çağırmak
bence
eğer
diğerinden
özel bir
fayda
elde etmiyorsanız
çok daha iyi
bir kere
bir geri dönüş
değeri var
geri dönüş
değeri
silinen
öve sayısı
auto
and
bir
sude
erase
özellikle
burada
gerekmiyor ama
ben
global fonksiyon
olduğunu
göstermek için
ismiyle
niteleyerek
namespace'i
çağırdım
birinci parametresi
container
nesnesi
şüphesiz
onu
lvalue
referans
semantiğiyle
alıyor
ikinci
re'si
silinecek
değer
örneğin
i
an
hatta
şöyle
yazalım
an
güzel
Türkçe
yazacağım
ya da
İngilizce
elams
deleted
erased
ve
jprint
back
çok daha kolay
enter the value
to remove
bir
beş tane
eleman
silindi
ve
container
size
da düştü
erase
ile ilgili
söylediğim
her şey
erase
if içinde
geçerli
global
erase
if
alvaritması
olması
dahil
hadi bu sefer
daha eğlenceli
bir şey
yapalım
arkadaşlar
vektörün
string
açılımı
svec
random
fill
svec
efendim
yüz
re
name
random
jprint
svec
evet
şimdi bakın
sefer
değişik bir
unarı
prediket
kullanalım
şarj
arkadaşlar
siyaf
enter
karakter
svec
ince
vektörden
içinde o
harpten
en az
bir tane
olanları
sileceğiz
o zaman
remove
birinci
ikinci
parametre
range
arkadaşlar
svec
begin
end
üçüncü
parametre
unarı
predikat
yani
bu
predikatın
true
verdiği
öyleri
silecek
o zaman
c
yi
capture
ediyorum
const
string
ref
s
artık
burayı
biliyorsunuz
return
s'in
find
c
eşit
değil
arkadaşlar
stringin
emposu
ama
c++
23'ü
destekliyorsa
ya böyle de
yazabilirim
23 öncesinde
s'in
find
c
arkadaşlar
eşit
değil
stringin
emposu
önce böyle
yazalım
unarı
predikatımızı
evet
bu
remove
if
ama yine
erase
remove
video mu
svec
erase
end
c
print
svec
önce
içinde o
harf olanlar
silinmiş olacak
evet
içinde
a olanları
sildik
pengin
sezer
nefes
belgin
cemil
nefes
uğur
nuri
ama
a'lar
yok
değil mi
tabi
böyle yazmak
yerine
şöyle
yazabilirdik
a
c++
23 için
isim
c
kestirme
arkadaşlar
return
s
build
project
c++ 23
de olmayabilir
evet
bakın
c++
deymiş
o yüzden
c++
s
contains
böylece
c++
23'e de
ilk göndermeyi
mi yapmış olduk
evet
bahsedeceğim
biraz
c++
daha sonra
böyle de
olabilirdi
evet
içinde
e olanları
sildi
ya da
şuradan
arkadaşlar
lambda ifademi
alayım
ve
auto
n
eşittir
erasive
aspect
unary
predicate
şunu da
yorum satırına
alalım
evet
bir karakter
girin
a
içinde
a olanlar
silindi
tabi fonksiyonun
geri dönüş
değeri
yine
silinen
ve sayısı
yazmıyorum artık
onu biliyoruz
süper
peki
üçüncü silme
algoritmamız
unic
bu da
bakın
mülakatların
çok tipik sorusu
arkadaşlar
şimdi
unic birkaç açıdan
önemli
önce
unic'in
sade bir
kullanımını
görelim
yine
vektörün
int açılımı
ivek
bakın
bu çok önemli
çünkü
bir algoritma
grubuyla
ilgisini göreceğiz
random film
ivek
iron
utility
hatta
biraz daha
azaltalım
arkadaşlar bakın
unique
svek
begin
end
ivek
begin
end
biraz dikkat
gezmemiz
gerekiyor
çünkü
şaşırtıcı
bir nokta
gelecek
şimdi
evet
ve
doğrudan
erase
remove
videomunu
kullanayım
arkadaşlar
efendim
neydi
konteynerim
ismi
ivek
erase
unique
ivek
end
şimdi range'in ne hale geldiğini
bir görmenizi istiyorum
jprint
ivek
arkadaşlar bakın şimdi
burada görüyorsunuz
2 4 2 3 3
ama burada bir tane 3
var
ondan sonra
1 1
ama burada bir tane 1 var
görüyoruz değil mi
4 4
arkadaşlar
0'dan sonra
evet
ve bir tane
4 var
unique'in ne olduğunu
şimdi daha iyi görüyoruz
değil mi
yalnız
burada
ilginç olan
bir başka noktaya değinelim
bu tür fonksiyonların
sadece
unique için değil
ileride başka örneklerini de göreceğiz
genelde şöyle bir
overload'a oluyor
burada
eşitliği sizce
nasıl sınadı
yani
konteynerdaki
öğeler
biraz da
şöyle
2 diyelim
daha iyi görelim
eşitliği nasıl sınadı
doğrudan
eşit eşit
operatörü
öyle değil mi
yani eşit eşit
operatörüyle bakarsak
buradaki
1'ler
birbirine eşit
fakat
fonksiyonumuzun
bir başka
overload'u
o eşitlik
karşılaştırması için
sizden bir
callable
istiyor
yani
binary
predikat
istiyor
şimdi örneği çok
dikkatli izlemenizi
istiyorum
örneğin ben
yine eski halini
alıyorum
hatta biraz daha
büyüteyim
örneğin ben
eşitlik
ilkesini
şöyle
tanıtabilirdim
arkadaşlar
izleyin
şimdi bir parametre
daha var
eşitlik
ilkesini
şöyle
tanıtabilirdim
eğer
ardışık
öğenin
İngilizcesiyle
auditisi
aynıysa
bu terim
biliyoruz
değil mi
yani
tekniği çiftliği
bizim
Türkçe
izleyin
auditisi
aynıysa
ben onları
eşit kabul
edeceğim
isterseniz
görüntüyü
sadeleştirmek
için
isim verelim
binary
predikatımıza
const
auto
f
pred
eşittir
int
x
y
bakınız
normalde
az önce
çağırdığım
şunu kullanıyor
aslında
return
x
eşit
y
takip edebiliyor muyuz
evet
ama şimdi ben
eşitliği
farklı bir şekilde
tanımlayacağım
arkadaşlar
x mod 2
eşit
y
mod 2
ise
bu ne demek
yani
ikisinin de
ikiye bölümünden
kalanlar
aynıysa
bu ne demek
işte o demek
yani ikisi de
tekse
ya da ikisi de
çiftse
ve şimdi
fonksiyonun
diğer
overloadunun
üçüncü
parametresine
f
pred
argüman olarak
geçtim
bakın
evet
arkadaşlar
çift
değil mi
neden
gitti
çünkü
de çift
çift
bakın bakın
buraya kadar
hepsi
gitti
neden
çünkü
benim eşitlik
kriterime göre
bunlar
birbirine
eşit
takip edebiliyor muyuz
dolayısıyla
renci ne hale
getirdim
bakın
ondan sonraki
ilk eşit olmayan
sayı
ondan sonra
örneğin şöyle
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
x
mod
eşit eşit
y
mod
son rakamları
eşitse eşit
kabul etmiş oldum
şimdi
anlaşıldı
anlaşıldı mı
evet
necmo
bakın
bakın da
nasıl
evet
ile 430
eşit kabul etti
burada da var
362 ile
anlaşıldı mı
arkadaşlar
eris remove
gibi
unique var mı
yani şöyle bir fonksiyon var mı
diyor arkadaşım
yani
şunu kast ediyor herhalde
bunu yazmak yerine
global bir unique olsa
arkadaşlar
ve
bulamasak biz onu
çünkü yok
yani
eris ve eris ip için var ama
unique için
yok
ha onu da bir gösterelim
bakın
unique ile ilgili
ilginç bir nokta da şu
izleyin
bakın bakın
önce range'i sıralıyorum
sonra unique hale getiriyorum
unique
eksik bir şey
kalmadı değil mi
kaldı
ivek
end
tekrar yazdırıyorum
çiğe print
ivek
doğal olarak
her bir değerden
bir tane kalıyor
anlaşıldı değil mi
arkadaşlar bu bir çok
klasik bir soru
hadi bakalım
bu soruyu çözmeyi de
size bırakıyorum
mülakatlarla
sorulan
sorularda
kim çıkıyor
sahneye
string
s
see out
enter
a string
fakat get line ile alıyorum
yani boşlukları da alacağım
to get line
arkadaşlar
efendim
see in
s
ve yazdırıyorum
see out
köşeli parantezler
stringimize ait değil
buraya kadar derleyip
çalıştıralım
evet
aklıma böyle bir
cümle girdiğince de
hiçbir cümle gelmiyor
evet
şöyle olsun
boşluk boşluk boşluk
bugün
bizim
kentte
boşluk boşluk
havalar
doğdu
arkadaşlar
boşluk karakterlerini
sileceksiniz
ama sayısını
bire indireceksiniz
yani yazının içinde
arka arkaya iki boşluk
olmayacak
şimdi normalde bu soru
sanki string ile ilgili bir soruymuş gibi görünse de
aslında
unique sorusu değil mi
ee
eğer
arda arda gelen iki karakter
ikisi de boşluk karakteri ise
Alihan Bravo
sileceksiniz
burada tabi yine
neden de faydalanmış oluyoruz
Alihan
sonuçta
stringde bir
container
onun
rengini de
kullanabilirim
o zaman
nasıl bir
unique işlemi yapmak
gerekiyor
unique
efendim
s'in
begini
endi
ve şimdi
binary predicate
char
c1
c2
arkadaşlar
return
suit
is
space
sunup
is space
c1
ve
arkadaşlar
is space
zaten namespace
direktörümüz varmış
is space
c2
yani c1
boşluk karakteri ise
white space karakterlerden
biri ise
c2
de white space
karakterlerinden
biri ise
bunları eşit
kabul ettik
s'in
erayzi
yine
container olduğu için
s'in
endi
bakalım yanlış
eksik bir şey
yazdık mı
enter a string
efendim
yine aynı şekilde
bugün
babalar
çok
doğdu
hasta
olmayalım
evet hasta
hasta olmuş
ama görüyorsunuz
boşluk karakterlerin
sayısı
gerçekten
bire düştü
anlamayan var mı
burada da yine
string'in de bir
stl
konteyneri olmasında
faydalanmış oldu
normalde tabii ki
string sınıfında böyle bir
fonksiyon olmasını
beklemeyin
hep böylece silme grubu
algoritmaları da bitirmiş
olduk
remove
remove if
ve arkadaşlar
unique
yalnız remove copy
ve remove copy if'i
bunlarla karıştırmayalım
onlar zaten başka
bireyince yazıyorlar
yani örneğin
bir tanesine örnek verelim
sadece
yine
vektörün
string açılımı
svec
random fill
random name
jprint
svec
şimdi bakın
ikinci bir
vektör var
vektörün
arkadaşlar
string açılımı
destvec
size t
len
cout
uzunluk
değeri
girin
c in
len
şimdi bakın
remove
copy if
birinci ikinci parametre
tahmin edebildiğiniz gibi
range'im
kaynak range'im
svec
begin
end
üçüncü parametre
arkadaşlar
hedef range başlangıcı
efendim
back insurter
yazılımı
destvec
iteratör başlık dosyası
back'i de doğru yazarsak
Allah'ın izniyle
back insurter
destvec
dördüncü parametresi
arkadaşlar
radicate
evet
bu uzunluk
mesela bu uzunluktan
fazla olanları
silelim
önce bunlardan kısaları
kalsın
len'i capture
ettim
const
string
ref
s
buradaki koşul
silinme koşulu
değil mi
örneğin
s'in
length'i
büyükse
len
arkadaşlar
ya da büyük eşitler olsun
o uzunluk dahil
siliyoruz
evet
aslında silmiyoruz
oraya kopyalamıyoruz
değil mi
kesinlikle
böylece
destvec yazdıralım
print
c
destvec
evet
şurada return ifadesini
her zamanki gibi
unutmuşum
hızı yazdığımda
hep şu
return statement
yerine
oradan ifadeyi
yazıyorum
evet
deneyelim
uzunluk değerini
girin
evet
5 ve 5'ten
büyükleri
silsin
kaya
saati
ve naz kaldı
bir örnek daha
evet
bu sefer
6 ve
uzunları
silsin
5'ler de
geldi
evet
remove
copy
if
remove
copy
belirli bir değeri
silerek
sözde
onu göstermiştik
remove
copy
koşulu
sağlayanlara
silinmiş
muamelesi
yaparak
kopyalıyor
evet
algoritmalara
sonra geri
döneceğiz
şimdi artık
yeni bir
başlangıç
yapalım
stl
containers
arkadaşlar
aslında ben şöyle
anlatmayı seviyorum
ama
stl
containerları
veri yapılarını
implemente eden
sınıflar
ama stl'in
kendisi böyle
söylemiyor
c++
standardı
böyle
söylemiyor
yani
c++
standart
örneğin
list
containerı
çifte bağlı
listedir
efendim
falanca
containerı
ikili arama
ağacıdır
demiyor
containerın
özelliklerini
söylüyor
yani
implementasyon
aslında
o koşulları
sağlayacak
herhangi bir
implementasyon
olabilir
ama
buradan çıkan
sonuç
şu ki
önce stl
containerlarının
tekrar
listesini
verelim
bir grup
sequence
containers
bir grup
associative
containers
bir grup
unordered
associative
containers
sequence
başta
stl
vektör
dec
ya da
iki şekilde
telaffuz ediliyor
list
forward list
string
stud
array
bunlar
sequence
container
arkadaşlar
şimdi
şunları daha
önceden konuşmuştuk
bir
containerların
ortak
interfezi var
yani
öyle fonksiyonlar
var ki
bir iki
istisna hariç
bütün
containerlerde
var
örneğin
bir
containerın
clear
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsanız
containerdaki
bütün
öğeleri
siliyor
ama
istisnalar
var
array
c dizlerini
sarmalayan
bir sınıf
olduğu için
burada
silme
diye bir şey
yok
dolayısıyla
bunun
clear fonksiyonu
olamaz
efendim
empty fonksiyonu
is empty
anlamında
boş mu
gibi
yani
öyle fonksiyonlar
var ki
empty
gibi
size
efendim
clear
gibi
bütün
containerlerde
var
bir iki
istisna hariç
fakat
bir de
bazı
fonksiyonlarda
bu grupların
ortak fonksiyonu
mesela
sequence
containerlerin
ortak
bazı fonksiyonları
var
associative
containerlerin
ortak
fonksiyonları
var
unordered
associative
containerlerin
ortak
fonksiyonu
var
orada
onları da
yazalım
set
multi
map
ve
multi
map
bunların
başına
unordered
sözcüğünü
getirirseniz
onlar da
unordered
associative
containerlerimiz
yani
şöyle
şimdi biz bu
containerlerin
hepsini
ayrıntılı
göreceğiz
yani böyle
yani bir
göz atma
şeklinde
değil
kursun en kapsamlı
bölümlerinden
bir tanesi de bu
klasik
iliyonlara da
bakacağız
çok tipik
ihtiyaç duyulan
işlemlerin
nasıl yapıldığını
göreceğiz
şüphesiz
interface'indeki
fonksiyonları
tanıyacağız
hangi fonksiyon
ne yapıyor
ne iş yapıyor
neye dikkat etmek
gerekiyor
gibi
ama önce
şu gruplama
hakkında
biraz daha
konuşalım
arkadaşlar
sequence
container grubunda
şu var
değil mi
öğelerin
bir sırası
var
yani
soyutlanmış
bir indeks
kavramı
var
üçüncü
öğe
beşinci
burada
indeks
kavramı
var
derken
bunlar
arka arka
contiguous
olmadığından
bahsetmiyorum
ama
lojik olarak
bir indeks
var
üçüncü
beşinci
yedinci
ve
ekleme
işlemleri
istediğimiz
bir konuma
yapılabiliyor
mesela
üçüncü
konuma
bir ekleme
yapıyorum
beşinci
konuma
bir ekleme
yapıyorum
ama
asosiyatif
konteynerlerde
ekleme
değerle yapılıyor
siz sadece
değeri veriyorsunuz
konteyner
o değerin
ekleneceği
yeri
kendi
biliyor
yani
karşılaştırmaya
dayalı
bir sıraya göre
konteynerin
iç düzeni
dolayısıyla
şu konuma
şunu insert
et
diyemeyiz
eğer
sentaks engelini
aşıp
belirli bir
konuma
istediğiniz değeri
eklemeye
kalkarsınız
sentaks
engelini
açtığınız
dahi
veri yapısını
bozmuş
korapt etmiş
İngilizcesiyle
ve tanımsız
davranış
oluşturmuş
olursunuz
arkadaşlar
bu konteynerler
içinde
küpesiz
en sık
kullanılan
vektör
aslında
konteynerı
bildiğimiz
tipik
diğer
programlama
dillerinin
de standart
kütüphanesinde
olan
dinamik
dizi
sınıfı
aslında biz
dinamik
dizi
sınıfından
bahsettik
daha doğrusu
dinamik
dizi
dynamic
array
veri yapısından
bahsettik
stil
string
sınıfını
anlatırken
zaten
vektörle
string
arasında
arkadaşlar
veri yapısı
implementasyon
tarafında
bir fark
yok
fark
stringin
onun da
dinamik
dizi olarak
tipik olarak
implemente edilmesi
fakat
yazılar için
özelleştirilmiş
bir
interfej
vektör ise
genelleştirilmiş
bir dinamik
dizi
neydi
dinamik
dizi
hemen
hatırlayalım
öğeler
allocate
edilmiş
bir bellek
bloğunda
contiguous
ve bir
kapasite
kavramı
var
size ve
kapasite
kavramı
var
kapasite
allocate
edilmiş
bellek
bloğunda
tutulabilecek
öğe sayısı
size ise
tutulmakta
olan
öğe sayısı
size
kapasiteye
eşit
olduğunda
artık
yeni bir
insertion
için
yer yok
storage yok
reallocation
olmak zorunda
zaten
vektör
konteynerının
en büyük
derdi
ya da
bizim için
en önemli
özelliği
bu
reallocation
işlemleri
arkadaşlar
çünkü
iteratörleri
pointerları
invalidate
edebiliyor
ve
tabii ki
ilave
maliyetle
çıkartıyor
taşıma
semantiği
tarafından da
tarafında da
bundan
bahsetmiştik
dolayısıyla
vektör
tipik bir
dinamitli
sınıfı
bu konteynerı
ben
çalışmak istiyorum
derseniz
bu konu
bittikten sonra
tabii ki
en fazla
önemi
ve belki
ilk sırayı
vektöre
ayırmalısınız
vektör
tipik olarak
dinamitli
yani
bizi ilgilendiren
indeksle
erişimin
constant
time'da
olması
sondan
silme
işlemlerinin
constant
time'da
olması
sondan
ekleme
işlemlerinin
arkadaşlar
amortized
constant
time'da
olması
ölçesiyle
amorte edilmiş
sabit zaman
ve
vektör
konteynerında
şu
implementasyona
bağlı
size
kapasiteye
eşit
olduğunda
bir
insertion
talebi
geldiğinde
kapasite
ne kadar
arttırılacak
bazı implementasyonlar
iki kat
arttırıyor
ycc
clank
gibi
fakat
nedense
microsoft
derleyicisi
bir buçuk
kat
arttırıyor
ve
onu
set edemiyorsunuz
yani
o bir template
parametresi
vesaire
değil
ya da
o
interpeste
onu belirleyecek
bir fonksiyon
yok
arkadaşlar
şimdi
çok sık
sorulan
bir soruyu
da ben
sorayım
burada
mülakatlarında
en klasik
sorularından
biri yeni
ama
mülakatta
sorulduğu için
değil de
üretimde
önemli olduğu
için
diyelim ki
elinizde
bir
konteyner
var
my
container
yani
bunlardan
herhangi biri
olabilir
hissediyorlar ki
şu
işi
yapın
siz de
iki ayrı
yol
görüyorsunuz
gerçekten
ikisi de
doğru
şekilde
onu
yapıyor
biri
bir
algoritmayı
çağırmak
yani
STL
algoritmalarından
birimi
çağırarak
diğeri ise
container'ın
public
interfeisinde
bulunan
bir
fonksiyonu
çağırarak
ama
ikisi de
sonuçta
aynı
işi
yapıyor
hangisini
tercih edersiniz
algoritmayı mı
container'ın
üye
fonksiyonu mu
evet
bu bir soru
cevapları
alalım
en azından
birkaç
arkadaşım
cevap
versin
muhammed
container
diyor
alian
algoritma
diyor
olsam
jenerik
ihtiyacımız
yoksa
üye
diyor
hayır jenerik
öyle olsaydı
zaten soruyu
ona göre
sorar
cevap
tabii ki
container'ın
üye
fonksiyonu
nedeni şu
nedenini
anlamanız
önemli
başka bir
sınırlayıcı
faktör
yok ise
arkadaşlar
algoritma
iteratörle
işlemi yapıyor
dolayısıyla
container'ın
içsel
implementasyonuna
ne yapamaz
erişme imkanı
yok
burası çok
önemli
ama
container'ın
üye fonksiyonu
iç organlarını
kullanabiliyor
bakın
bunun en tipik
örneği
ben
reverse
algoritmasını
anlatırken
size ne
demiştim
aman
dedim
liste için
ben
reverse
algoritmasını
kullanıyorum
ama
listenin
kendi
reverse
fonksiyonu
var
oysa
listenin
iteratörleri
bidirectional
iteratör
yani
reverse
algoritması
zaten
bidirectional
iteratör
kategorisini
destekliyor
hani
mesela
sort
deseydim
algoritması
random
access
teratör
gerektiriyor
listi
zaten
sort
algoritmasıyla
edemem
ama
reverse
ikisini de
yapabilirim
ama
arkadaşlar
hatırlayın
şimdi
bu
tipik
olarak
bir
node
temelli
veri yapısı
değil mi
çifte
bağlı
liste
list
node
nasıl
bir şey
hatırlayalım
içinde
datayı
tutuyor
arkadaşlar
bu
bizim
bir
node
olsun
yani
çifte
val
listede
double
link
listede
bir
node
olsun
şu
data
iki tane de
pointer
var
öyle değil mi
evet
şöyle diyorsan
öyle
tipik
implementasyon
böyle
node'un içinde
bir
data
var
bir de
iki tane
pointer
var
tipik olarak
öyle değil mi
biri
bulabilirsek
tabii
tekrar
arkadaşlar
biri
container'daki
bir sonraki
öğeyi gösteren
pointer
bir sonraki
öğeyi tutan
düğümü gösteren
pointer
nereye kayboldu
ben de anlamadım
ama
altıncı sayfaymış
evet burada
diğeri de
bir sonraki
öğeyi tutan
düğümü gösteren
pointer
hani tipik olarak
birine
prev
next diyorlar ya
evet bu
p olsun
bu da
prev
olsun
e şimdi
bakınız
bazı
algoritmalarda
swap
gerektiriyor
mesela
reverse
n tipik örneği
algoritmasını
hatırlayın
range'deki
öğe sayısının
yarısı kadar
dönen bir
döngü olacak
böyle ya da
böyle
ilk öğeyle
son öğeyi
ikinci öğeyle
sondan ikinci
öğeyi
üçüncü
öğeyle
sondan
üçüncü
öğeyi
takas
yapacaksınız
algoritmaya
bakarsanız
kodunun da
böyle olduğunu
rahatlıkla
görebilirsiniz
cppreference.com'dan
ama şimdi
şöyle bir
problem var
mesela
benim
listemde
yani list
konteynerimde
fighter
türünden
öğeler
tutulsaydı
ve fighter
öğeleri
size of
yani
storage ihtiyacı
olarak çok büyük
olsaydı
örneğin
100 byte
o zaman
listeyi
reverse
ederken
algoritmasını
kullanırsam
reverse
algoritması
ne yapıyor
iteratör konumundaki
öğeleri
reverse ediyor
swap ediyor
ama arkadaşlar
biliyorsunuz
bağlı listede
ya da
not demelli
veri yapısında
bunu yapmama
gerek yok ki
eğer
boyu büyükse
neden bunları
takas edeyim ki
düğümün içindeki
pointerları
takas edelim
swap ederim
dolayısıyla
diyelim ki
benim sistemde
pointerlar
4 byte
4 byte'lık
veriyi
swap etme
maliyeti
çok daha düşük
ama diyelim ki
data
100 byte
200 byte
dolayısıyla
siz
algoritmayı
çağırdığınız zaman
arkadaşlar
algoritma
fiilen
bu swap işlemini
öğe üstünde
yapmak zorunda
çünkü
düğümlere
erişme
şansı yok
ama
listin kendi
reverse fonksiyonu
düğümlere
erişme
şansına
sahip
dolayısıyla
düğümün içindeki
pointerları
reverse ederek
swap ederek
özürlerim
bu işi
yapabilir
ve bazen de
aman dikkat
arkadaşlar
bazen de
maliyet
doğrudan
algoritmanın
karmaşıklığıyla
da ilgili
mesela
en basit örnek
find
algoritması
find'ı
hatırlıyorsunuz
ne yapıyor
birinçte
bir öğeyi
buluyor
ama
linear search
soru
ben
set
konteynerında
bir öğeyi
aramak için
find fonksiyonunu
çağırabilir miyim
yani çağırabilir miyim
derken
iyi olur mu
anlamında değil
find
algoritmasıyla
bunu bulabilir miyim
cevap
evet
ama
iki tane ayrı
problem var
bir tanesi
find
tek tek
döngüyle
bakıyor
aradığım
değer mi
oysa
set in find
fonksiyonu
ikili arama
ağacındaki
aramayı
yapıyor
değil mi
yani
log n
karmaşıklığında
biri
o n
karmaşıklığında
öbürü
log n
karmaşıklığında
ama başka
farklar da var
o yüzden çok
dikkatli olmalıyız
mesela
find
algoritması
değerin
aradığım
değer olup
olmadığını
sınamak için
equal
fonksiyonunu
kullanıyor
equal
to'yu
kullanıyor
yani eşit eşitle
karşılaştırmayı
yapıyor
ama
setin
kendi
fonksiyonları
equality
değil
equivalence
kavramını
kullanıyor
yani örneğin
a küçüktür
b
değil
ve aynı
zamanda
b küçüktür
a değil
böyle bir
ifadeyle
karşılaştırmayı
yapıyor
o yüzden
aman dikkat
üye fonksiyonu
çok özel bir
durum yoksa
her zaman
üye fonksiyonu
çağırmak
diğer alternatife
göre
daha iyi
zaten bu
esterle ilgili
sorulan
tipik sorulardan
biri bu
biri de şuna
dikkat etmek
gerekiyor
ben tek tek
söylemeyeceğim
bundan sonraki
konteynerları
işlediğimizde
arkadaşlar
bir işi
yapmak için
en tane
fonksiyon
çağırmak
yerine
tek bir
fonksiyon
çağrısı
tipik olarak
maliyeti
azaltıyor
yani örneğin
diyelim ki
konteynera
beş tane
v ekleyeceksiniz
bir
beş kere
diyelim ki
insert fonksiyonunu
çağırarak
bu işi yaptınız
iki
hayır
öyle bir fonksiyon
var ki
ismine
önemli değil
yine insert
olabilir
ama bir çağrıya
uygun argümanları
verdiğinizde
o işi yapıyor
beşini birden
insert ediyor
örneğin bu
initializer list
parametreyle bir
insert olabilir
range
parametreyle bir
insert olabilir
her zaman
tercihiniz ne
olmalı
bir fonksiyon
çağrısıyla
yapabiliyorsam
muhtemelen
sıra dışı
belki çok az örnek
olabilir
en tane
fonksiyon
çağrısıyla
yaptığım
işe göre
daha düşük
bir
maliyet
taşıyordur
bir ara vereceğiz
saat 21.05
21.25
de devam edeceğiz
evet hemen
vektör konteynerına
başlayalım
o zaman
hızlı bir şekilde
arkadaşlar
vektör konteynerini
incelerken
öğrenirken
aynı zamanda
sequence
konteynerların
ortak
ara yüzünü
göreceğiz
ayrıca
hemen
bütün
konteynerlerde
olan
üye fonksiyonlara
bakmış olacağız
dolayısıyla
vektöre
biraz daha fazla
zaman ayıracağız
ama bu
diğer konteynerlerde
bu kaybettiğimiz
zamanı
telafi edeceğiz
yine
bazı
durumlarla
iteratör
invalidation gibi
ilk defa
vektör sınıfı
üstünde
tanışacağız
daha sonra
bu bize
zaman kazandıracak
şimdi
vektörün
başlık dosyası
vektör
STL
standart
açıkça
arkadaşlar
dinamik olarak
büyüyebilen
bir diziden
bahsediyor
hani veri yapısı
olarak
dinamik dizi
veri yapısı
demiyor ama
olması gereken
sağlanması gereken
koşulları
belirtiyor
burada
vektör sınıfının
bir
sınıf şablonu
olduğunu
çenerik bir sınıfı
söyleyerek
başlayalım
birinci
template parametresi
konteynerde
tutulacak
öğenin
türü
ikinci
template parametresi
dinamik
berlek yönetiminden
sorumlu
allocator
dediğimiz
template parametresi
type name
a
bu
konteynerların
hemen hepsinde
böyle bir
parametre var
stud array
haricinde
yani
dinamik olarak
allocation varsa
mutlaka bir
allocator
parametresi var
ve bu
allocator
parametresi
default olarak
arkadaşlar
standart
kütüphanenin
allocator
sınıf şablonunun
t-specialization'ını
alıyor
yani
böyle bir
sınıftan
bahsediyoruz
class
vektör
biz
uygulamaların
hemen hepsinde
standart
allocator'ı
kullanacağız
ama özellikle
gömle sistem tarafında
çalışan arkadaşlar
oraya uygun
özel bir
allocator
kullanıyor
olabilecekler
ama şimdilik biz
önce standartına
bir bakalım
bu da şu
demek
ben eğer
arkadaşlar
örneğin
vektörde
dinamik
dizide
int tutmak
istiyorsam
vektörün
int açılımı
zaten bütün
konteynerlerde
hep ilk öhe
konteynerde
tutulacak
öhenin
türü
böyle yazmam
allocator
parametresi
için varsayılan
template
argümanı
allocator'ın
int açılımını
seçmiş
olmam
demek
vektörün
int açılımı
bait açılımı
vektörün
string
açılımı
arkadaşlar
mesela
string'in
kendisi de
bir
konteyner
değil mi
dolayısıyla
vektörün
string açılımı
dediğimde
template
argümanı
olarak da
yine aslında
bir
konteynerı
kullanıyorum
bu konteyner
yine
vektör
konteynerının
kendisi de
olabilir
mesela
vektörün
int
specialization
şimdi
using
bildirimi
yapalım
orası
dikkatinizi
dağıtmasın
şöyle yazayım
örneğin
vektörün
int
açılımı
tabi
type
alias
bildirimi
bu tür
durumlarda
tercih ediliyor
ama
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir
sorun
yok
yine
bahsetmiştik
modern
C++
öncesinde
bu
maximal
manch
kuralına
takılıyordu
burada
bir boşluk
vermek
gerekiyordu
ama
şimdi
artık
modern
C++
ile birlikte
bu
engel
aldırıldı
bu
başka bir
konteyner
da olabilir
değil mi
mesela
her bir
elemanı
bir
bağlı liste
olan
bir liste
böyle bir
vektörde
olabilir
en son
söyleyeceğimiz
şeylerden
birini
en başta
söyleyelim ki
yine hem
üretimde çok önemli
hem de böyle
mülakatlarla çok sık
sorulan bir soru
arkadaşlar
vektörün
boğul açılımına
dikkat
vektörün
boğul açılımı
içinde boğul
tutan bir
vektör
değil
bu bir
partial
specialization
yani
vektörün
boğul açılımı
primary
template'i
kullanmıyor
bu
ayrı bir
specialization
yerden
kazanç
sağlamak
için
boğul
yerine
bu
boğul
değerleri
bit
seviyesinde
tutuyor
çok da
eleştirilen
bir
karar
ama artık
değiştirme
imkanımız
yok
dolayısıyla
vektörün
boğul açılımına
fiilen
boğul
tutmaması
bazı
noktalarda
işimize
geliyor
olabilir
fakat
bazen de
özellikle
vektördeki
öğeye
erişmede
proxy
class
kullanıldığı
için
dikkat etmezsek
başımıza
ciddi dert
açabiliyor
diyelim
şimdiden
vektörün
boğul açılımını
böyle bir
saptamayla
onu
belirli bir yere
kadar
kullanmayacağız
sonra ona
ayrıca
değineceğim
arkadaşlar
bu bir
sequence
container
ve
sequence
container'ların
tipik
interface'ine
sahip
burada
özellikle
constructor
grubu
ve get
fonksiyonlarına
öncelik
tanıyacağız
arkadaşlar
bir kere
vektör
sınıfı
diğer
sequence
container'larda
olduğu gibi
belirli
get
fonksiyonlar
var
bunlardan
en önemlisi
size
fonksiyonu
string
sınıfında
da bahsetmiştik
container
sınıfların
size
fonksiyonu
container'da
tutulmakta
olan
v sayısını
döndürüyor
ve
size
fonksiyonunun
her zaman
geri dönüş
değeri
bir
nested
type
olan
arkadaşlar
size
type
vektör
için
string
size
türünün
eş ismi
yani
burada
vektör
için
string
size
type'ın
t olduğu
bunun
işaretsiz
bir
tam sayı
türü
olduğu
işaretsiz
tam sayı
türüyle
ilgili
biliyorsunuz
daha
C kursundan
öğrendiklerimizi
dikkatli
olmamız gerekiyor
özellikle
işaretli
değerlerle
karşılaştırdığımızda
tür dönüşümü
işaretsiz
yöne
yapılıyor
size
fonksiyonu
değerini
get ediyor
kapasite
fonksiyonu
kapasiteden
bahsetmiştik
kapasite
değerini
get eden
fonksiyonlar
her ikisinin
geri dönüş
değeri de
stringin
size
type'ı
empty
fonksiyonu
yine
konteynerların
hepsinde
mevcut
empty
fonksiyonu
konteyner
boş mu
sorusuna
cevap veriyor
değil mi
burada isimlendirme
konversiyonuna
dikkat
birçok
programlama
dilinin
standart
kütüphanesinde
empty
ismi
make
empty
anlamında
yani
boşaltmak
anlamında
yani
size
sıfıra
düşürmek
anlamında
oysa
bizim
STL'imizde
konteynerların
empty
fonksiyonu
post
dünya
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
ve
is
empty
anlamında
fonksiyonu
boolean
döndürüyor
eğer
konteyner
boşsa
boolean
true
döndürüyor
konteyner
boş
değilse
boolean
false
döndürüyor
ve
tabi ki
arkadaşlar
const
dünya
fonksiyon
arkadaşlar
belirli fonksiyonlar
artık
STL'de
atribütleri
da içeriyor
bir derste
bahsetmiştim
no discard
atribütünü
inşallah
atribütleri
ayrı bir derste
detaylı olarak
anlatacağım
ama
empty
fonksiyonu
size
bunları çağırıp da
geri dönüş
değerini
kullanmamak
lojik hataya
işaret ettiği
için
bu fonksiyonlar
no discard
derleyicilerin
implementasyonda
yani örneğin
empty
fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde
çağırırsam
benim derleyicim
muhtemelen
sizin derleyicinizde
arkadaşlar
bir uyarı
mesajı verecek
no discard
atribütüyle
bildirildiği
için
o zaman
tekrar edelim
size
get ediyor
kapasite
empty
bütün
konteynerler için
is empty
anlamında
bizde
make empty
anlamında
bir empty
yok
bu işi yapan
fonksiyon
clear
destel
konteynerlarının
string
dahil
clear
fonksiyonu
konteynerda
tutulan
öğelerin
hepsini
siliyor
ve
konteynerı
arkadaşlar
size
sıfır
olacak
hale
getiriyor
arkadaşlar
şimdi
konteynerlarla
ilgili
önce
genel bazı
bilgileri de
verelim
ondan sonra
özelde
vektöre
ayrıntılı
olarak
inceleyelim
modern
C++
konteyner
semantiğinde
önemli
değişiklikler
yaptı
bir kere
daha önce
taşıma
semantiği
yoktu
konteynerlar
kopyalama
semantiğine
göre
çalışıyordu
ve referans
semantiğine
göre
değil
bu ne
demek
yani
örneğin
bizim
şöyle
x
y
gibi
değişkenlerimiz
olsa
biz
konteynerın
herhangi bir
ekleme
fonksiyonuna
örneğin
pushback
fonksiyonuna
argüman
olarak
x'i
geçsek
x'in
kendisini
mi
konteynera
koymuş
oluyoruz
yoksa
bir
kopyasını
mı
cevap
tabii ki
kopyasını
eskiden
beri
böyleydi
yani
örneğin
konteynera
insert
ettiğiniz
öğeyi
değiştirdiğinizde
x
değişecek
mi
hayır
ya da
x'i
değiştirdiğinizde
konteynerda
tutulan
öğey
değişecek
mi
hayır
o yüzden
modern
C++
öncesi
konteynerların
arkadaşlar
konteynerlarda
tutulacak
öğeyi ilişkin
türün
copy
constructible
olma
zorunluluğu
vardı
çünkü
ekleme
işlemleri
kopyalama
yoluyla
yapılıyordu
ama
şimdi
ilerleyen
derslerde
haftalarda
neleri
göreceğiz
yani
konteynerın
bize sağladığı
hangi olanaklar
var
bir
arka
konteynerların
ekleme
fonksiyonları
benim
tabirimde
move
overloadları
var
yani
örneğin
daha önce de
bahsetmiştik
vektör sınıfını
düşünün
kafanızda
şöyle canlandırın
template
olmasının
dışında
plus
vektör
herhangi bir
ekleme
insertion
fonksiyonunu
alın
örneğin
public
pushback
iki tane
var
bu bütün
insert fonksiyonları
için böyle
bir pushback
diyor ki
mesela diyelim ki
vektörün
string açılımı
bir pushback
diyor ki
ben
l
value'ları
istiyorum
diğer pushback
diyor ki
ben
r
value'ları
istiyorum
böylece
l
value'ları
alan
bunun
bir
kopyasını
vektörde
oluşturuyor
yani
vektöre
eklenecek
öğe için
ilgili sınıfın
copy
konstruktörünü
çağırıyor
ama
r value
referans
parametreli
olan
vektöre
eklemek
için
eklenecek
öğeyi
sınıfın
move
konstruktörüne
çağrı yaparak
ekliyor
bu
sadece
vektör
sınıfı
için
değil
sadece
vektör
sınıfının
insert
fonksiyonları
için
değil
bütün
konteynerların
insert
fonksiyonları
için
geçerli
böylece
biz
bundan
ne şekilde
istifade
ediyoruz
a
herhangi bir
konteynera
l value
expression'ı
bir konteynerın
üye fonksiyonuna
verirsek
onun kopyası
çıkartılacak
r value
expression
verirsek
o
konteynera
koyulmak için
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanılacak
bunun getirdiği
taşıma
semantiğinin
getirdiği
bir başka
önemli nokta
artık
copy
constructible
olması
gerekmiyor
konteynerda
tutulan
üyelerin
konteynera
eklenmesi
için
çünkü
move only
type'larda
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanarak
konteynera
eklenebilir
örneğin
vektörde
bir move only
type olan
unique
ptr
türünden
nesneler
tutabilir
miyim
evet
vektörde
yine diyelim ki
off stream
sınıfı
türünden
nesneler
tutabilir
miyim
evet
ama onları
eklerken
taşıma
semantiğinden
faydalanacağız
bu
eski
C++'a
göre
çok
önemli bir
ne diyelim
yenilik
eski
C++'la
modern
C++'ı
karşılaştırdığımız
zaman
önemli bir
başka yenilik
eski
C++'la
yeni
C++'lar
arasında
konteynerların
emplace
fonksiyonları
daha önce
biraz bahsetmiştik
içinde
emplace
fiili geçen
fonksiyonlar
örneğin
emplace
back
front
gibi
arkadaşlar
emplace
hint
duruma göre
bunlar
konteynerın
tutacağı
nesneyi
oluşturmak
için
ne
sınıfın
copy
konstruktorını
ne
move
konstruktorını
çağırıyorlar
kendilerine
gönderilen
argümanları
perfect forwarding
mekanizmasıyla
sınıfın
konstruktorına
geçiyorlar
pas ediyorlar
yani
içinde
emplace
ismi geçen
fiili geçen
herhangi bir
fonksiyonda
hemen ne düşünmelisiniz
ben buna
argümanları
göndereceğim
benim ona
gönderdiğim
argümanları
perfect forwarding
mekanizmasıyla
yani
value
kategoriyi
ve
constness'ı
koruyarak
o da
sınıfın
konstruktorına
argüman olarak
geçecek
böylece
copy
konstruktorı
olmasa da
move
only
type'lar
kaçta
geldi
dediniz
diyor
emiran
arkadaşlar
modern
c++
çünkü
11'den
önce
move
konstruktor
assignment
yoktu
sağ taraf
referans
kavramı
yoktu
modern
c++
başlangıcı
standardı
evet
o zaman
artık
konteynere
öğe eklemek için
öğelerin
copy
constructible
olması
zorunluluğu
yok
a
move
konstruktorla
öğeler
konteynırda
konteynırın
sağladığı
bellek
alanında
oluşturulabilir
ya da
emplace
fonksiyonları
vasıtasıyla
doğrudan
öğenin
konstruktorına
emplace
fonksiyonlarına
geçilen
argümanlar
perfect forward
edilebilir
peki
decati
bir soru
ben
bir
konteynırda
nesnelerin
kendisini
tutabilir miyim
yani
gerçekten
şunu istesem
int x
y
z
böyle değişkenlerim
var
tabii
çök değerde
değil
ve ben
bunların
kendisini
konteynırda
tutmak istiyorum
yani
x'i değiştirdiğimde
konteynırdaki
öğe
değişecek
konteynırdaki
öğeyi
değiştirdiğimde
x değişecek
kendi referans
semantiğiyle
konteynırı
kullanmak
istiyorum
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
olanak yok
onu baştan
söyleyelim
yani örneğin
vektörün
int açılımı
yerine
vektörün
int ref
açılımını
kullanayım
hayır
böyle bir
olanak yok
ama
şunlar
var
a
arkadaşlar
ilerleyen
haftalarda
göreceğimiz
punctual
başlık
dosyasında
referans
sarmalayıcı
bir sınıfımız
var
bu sınıfın
ismi
reference
wrapper
kendisi
bir sınıf
dolayısıyla
konteynerın
örneğin
t ref
açılımını
oluşturamıyoruz
ama
konteynerın
reference
wrapper
specializationı
açılımını
kullanabiliyoruz
yani ne
demek
örneğin
ben
vektörün
lütfen
süreçisin
bildirimi
yapmamam
nedeniyle
biraz karmaşık
görünse de
reference
wrapper
string
açılımı
evet
böyle bir
açılım
specialization
kullandığım
zaman
bu türün
kendisi
zaten
adı üstünde
referans
olarak
kullanmaya
yönelik
bir wrapper
olduğu için
dolayısıyla
konteynerda
öğelere
referans
tutmuş
olacağım
dolaylı olarak
bir başka
seçenek
konteynerda
nesnelerin
adreslerini
tutmak
yani örneğin
vektörün
int
yıldız
açılımı
eleman
olarak
pointer
to int
tutan
bir vektör
dolayısıyla
adreslerini
aldığım
nesnelerin
adreslerini
bu vektör
kullanabilir
ama
dinamik ömürlü
nesneleri
tutmak için
böyle bir
ihtiyaç olduğunda
bunun yerine
daha çok
yine
smart pointer
sınıflarını
kullanıyoruz
yani örneğin
vektörün
string
pointer'ı
açılımı
yerine
vektörün
unique
ptr'ın
string
açılımı
açılımını
kullanıyoruz
bütün bunları
zaman içinde
göreceğiz
efendim
size'dan
kapasiteden
empty'den
bahsettik
sequence
konteynerların
hemen
constructor
grubuna
değinelim
arkadaşlar
bu
constructor
grubu
bütün
sequence
konteynerları
için
neredeyse
ortak
bir
default
constructor
vektörün
int
açılımı
ivek
arkadaşlar
bir
vektör nesnesini
default
initialize
ederseniz
ya da
value
initialize
ederseniz
ister
default
initialize
edin
ister
value
initialize
edin
bu durumda
container
sınıfın
default
constructor
ını çağırmış
olursunuz
default
constructor
tahmin
etmek
zor
değil
size
sıfır
olan
bir
vektör
oluşturuyor
yani
default
construct
ettikten
sonra
şunlar
garanti
altında
size
fonksiyonu
sıfır
döndürecek
empty
fonksiyonu
true
değer
döndürecek
hemen
bakın
cout
ivek'in
size
hızlı
bir
şekilde
iostream
başlık
dosyasını
ekleyelim
efendim
kapasite
fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
ve
empty
fonksiyonunu
çağıralım
bu
bin
diğeri
şu anda
formatında
yazacak
görüyorsunuz
arkadaşlar
empty
fonksiyonu
true
döndürdü
efendim
size
fonksiyonu
ve kapasite
narrowing
geçerli mi
derken
emirantam
olarak ne
kastediyorsunuz
ne anlamda
narrowing
conversion
den bahsediyoruz
evet
peki
devam edelim
tam soruyu
anlamamış
olabilirim
hayır hayır
o value
initialization
o şey
değil
o
arkadaşlar
ona bir
değer geçmiyorsunuz
zaten
bu
value
initialization
demek
küme parantezinin
içini
boş bırakmak
demek
anlaşıldı
değil mi
bunu neyle
karıştırmayalım
initializer list
konstruktörünü
karıştırmayalım
zaten oraya da
geleceğiz
şimdi
o zaman
default
konstruktör
öyle tutmayan
bir vektör oluşturuyor
bu arada
hemen şunu
söyleyeyim
bakın bir
konteyner
boşsa
onun
iteratör veren
fonksiyonlarını
çağırmanızda
hiç de engel
yok
yani örneğin
auto
beg
eşittir
ivek
begin
auto
end
eşittir
ivek
end
hiçbir şekilde
undefined
behavior
değil
bunların
karşılaştırılması
da
undefined
behavior
değil
yani örneğin
şu karşılaştırmalardan
hiçbiri
hata değil
beg
eşit
end
beg
eşit
değil
end
beg
küçük
end
gibi
vektörün
iteratörleri
random access
iteratör
ve daha sonra
c++20 ile de
contiguous
iteratör
kategorisinde
vektörün
öğeleri
bellekte
contiguous
olmak zorunda
tek bir
bellek bloğunda
olmak zorunda
arkadaşlar
bu da şu
demek
aslında
vektörde
tutulan
öğelerin
konteynerin
ilkinin
adresini
ki onu
veren
bir
üye fonksiyon
var
ilkinin
adresini
bir
si
apisine
bir
dizinin
ilk
elemanının
adresi
olarak
geçmemde
hiçbir engel
yok
burası
önemli
ama
bakın
daha önceki
derslerimizde de
söylemiştik
boş bir
konteynerin
iteratörünü
begin
in fonksiyonundan
aldığınız
iteratörü
dereferens
etmek
boş
ya da
dolu
herhangi bir
vektörün
end fonksiyonunun
verdiği
iteratörü
dereferens
etmek
her zaman
anımsız davranış
undependent
behavior
iteratör
dereferensing
hiçbir şekilde
exception
prove
etmiyor
yine aynı
şekilde
iteratör
karşılaştırması
iteratörlerin
artı artı
operatörüyle
arttırılması
eğer
eksi eksi
destekliyorsa
operatörüyle
eksiltilmesi
bunların
hiçbiri
exception
prove eden
işlemler
değil
devam
arkadaşlar
iteratör veren
fonksiyonlarımızı
daha önce
konteynerlarda
söylemiştik
ama
tekrar edelim
ibeg'in
begin'i
normal iteratör
göndürüyor
end'i
end konumu
c begin
ve c
end fonksiyonları
c begin
ve c
end fonksiyonları
host
iteratör döndürüyor
eğer en az
bidirectional
iteratör
kategorisinde ise
r begin
ve r
end fonksiyonları
r begin
ve r
end fonksiyonları
reverse
iteratör döndürüyor
cr begin
cr end
fonksiyonları
host
reverse
iteratör
döndürüyor
dolayısıyla örneğin
auto
iter
dediğim zaman
auto type
didakşında
iterin türü
vektörün
int açılımının
iteratörü
ama şimdi
vektörün
int açılımının
const iteratörü
vektörün
int açılımının
reverse
iteratörü
vektörün
int açılımının
const reverse
iteratörü
üründen olacak
iter
burada
ilginç bir
constructora
hemen değinelim
arkadaşlar
eğer
parantezi
kullanırsanız
burada
küme parantez ile
parantez arasında
önemli fark var
maalesef
buradaki
bir
constructor
size t
parametreli
constructır
ve
konteynerı
bu kadar
tane
value
initialize edilmiş
öğe ile
başlatıyor
bu ne demek
value
initialize edilmesi
demek
konteynerde
tutulan
öğeler
aritmetik
türlerden ise
sıfır
değeriyle
başlatılması
pointer
türlerinden ise
null pointer
değeriyle
başlatılması
ve
boodin
safons
değeriyle
başlatılması
demek
yani örneğin
ben
bu
konteynerı
öğelerini
o ya da
bu şekilde
yazdırırsam
çünkü
yazdırmanın da
çok sayıda
yolu var
ona da ayrıca
değineceğiz
ben
şimdilik
pratik olsun
diye
utility
başlık
dosyamdaki
jprint
fonksiyonu ile
yazdırıyorum
oraya
aldırmayın
önemli olan
değerlerin ne
olduğunu
görmeniz
eğer bu
sınıf
türünden
üyelere
sahip
olsaydı
arkadaşlar
bu arada
biraz
müsaade
evet
bakınız
güzel bir örnek
örneğin
date
başlık
dosyası
varmış
burada
eğer
kodlar
varsa
arkadaşlar
evet
varmış
bakın
mesela
yanlış hatırlamıyorsam
date'in
default
constructları
arkadaşlar
ne yapıyordu
tarihi ile
başlatıyordu
örneğin
vektörün
date
açılımı
başlık
dosyasını
dahil
ediyorum
devec
ve
jprint
devec
newline
tabi
kodlar
koyulmuş mu
bilmiyorum
ama sanırım
evet
bakın
hepsi
default
construct edildi
ya da şuna
bakınız
vektörün
string açılımı
svec
bu sefer
range
ve sforluk
kullanıyorum
bu arada
range ve sforluk
ayrıntılı
anlatacağım
önümüzdeki günlerde
ama şimdilik
kez
kullanım
const
autoref
s
svec
default
construct edildiğini
göstermek için
yazı
zaten bir
karaktere
sahip değil
ama
örneğin
string'in
length
komisyonunu
çağırıp
sıfır
olacak
değil mi
hepsi
default
construct edildiği
için
arkadaşlar
buradan şöyle
bir sonuç
çıkıyor
bakın
konteynerların
bu
konstruktörü
için
konteynerda
tutulan
öğenin
default
constructible
olması
gerekiyor
yani
bir sınıfın
default
constructörü
yoksa
mesela
date
sınıfının
default
constructörü
olmasaydı
az önceki
kod
syntax
atalsını
oluşturacaktı
bu
bütün
sequence
konteynerlerde
böyle bir
size t
parametreyle
constructörü
var
ben bu
constructöra
field
constructörü
diyorum
arkadaşlar
evet
sınıfın
constructörü
grubu
şunları
söylemeye
gerek yok
copy
constructor
move
bunlardan
zaten
daha önce
bahsetmiştik
örneğin
şöyle bir
vektörüm
olsaydı
tabi
arada
başka
kodlar
var
auto
x
eşittir
svek
x için
copy
constructor
çağrılacaktı
ama
eşittirin
sağ tarafındaki
ifade
bir
r
value
expression
olsaydı
x için
move
constructor
çağrılacaktı
copy
constructor
move
tabi ki
var
arkadaşlar
ikinci bir
önemli
constructor
belirli sayıda
belirli değerle
başlatan
öğeleri
örneğin
bir tane
değişkenimiz
olsun
int
eval
değişkenimizin
değeri
olsun
vektörün
string
açalımı
svek
10 tane
ibal
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
10 tane
ibal
yazdıralım
fakat
burada
mülakatlarda
çok sık
sorulduğunu
söylemiştim
bu sorunu
parantezde
küme parantezi
farklı anlam taşıyor
çünkü
container
sınıfların
initializer list
parametreli
konstruktörü
da var
arkadaşlar
örneğin
şöyle yazsaydım
ibal
ikisi arasındaki
farka bakın
buna
vek 1
diyelim
diğerine
vek 2
diyelim
hocam
initializer list
konstruktör
c++
11'de mi
geldi
c++
tabi ki
11'den
önce
initializer list
yoktu
arkadaşlar
şimdi
güzel de bir soru
olsam
beyin
sorusu
onunla ilgili
bir hikaye
anlatacağım
ama önce
şunu göstereyim
vek 2
burada da
parantez
şimdi bakın
vek 2'nin
size
arkadaşlar
eski
kodlarda
sorun olmadı mı
hayır
çünkü eskiden
küme paranteziyle
ihtiyar verme
yoktu ki
olsam
küme paranteziyle
ihtiyar verme de
modern c++
geldi
yani eskiden
zaten böyle bir
sentaks olamazdı
çünkü küme parantezi
initialization'da
kullanılmıyordu
onun kendisi de
modern c++
geldi
anlaşıldı mı
şimdi bakın
arkadaşlar
vek 1'in
size
vek 2'nin
vek 1'in
size
vek 2'nin
10 olduğunu
görüyorsunuz
ya da
şuna bakın
c print
vek 1
vek
yani küme parantezi
kullandığınızda
initializer list
konstruktörünün
önceliği var
bu vektörle ilgili
bir özellik değil
daha önce
anlatmıştım
bir derste
yani kendimizde
bir sınıf yazsak
o sınıfa
initializer list
parametreli
bir konstruktör
koysak
onun diğer
konstruktörlere göre
küme parantezi
kullanıldığında
seçilebilirliği
olacak
burayı anladık mı
dolayısıyla
aman burada
dikkat
arkadaşlar
string sınıfı
için de
aynı şeyi söylemiştim
initializer list
konstruktör ile
diğer field
konstruktörü
birbiriyle
karıştırmayalım
ama bu sadece
tabi
ham sayı tutan
vektörler için
değil
örneğin vektörün
string açılımı
svek
arkadaşlar
efendim
10 tane
necati
cprint
svek
ya da
vektörün
artık date sınıfımızda
kullanım
date açılımı
dvek
10 tane
arkadaşlar
efendim
bugün
ayın kaçıymış
cprint
svek
bvek
new life
evet
kasım
pazartesi
arkadaşlar
farklı
konteynerlar
birbirine
neyha
bu arada
Oğuzhan Bey'in
sorusu için
bir saptama
yapacaktım
bakın şimdi
eskiden
c++
kodu yazanlar
ben mesela
cennetlik
neden
çünkü
çilesini biz çektik
daha da siz
kamıştınız
arkadaşlar şimdi
initializer list
konstruktör yoktu
bakın
daha önce bir derste
belki söylemiş olabilirim
şöyle yapıyorduk
önce bir dizi
tanımlıyorduk
bu değerlerle
başlatmak için
vektörün
ya da başka
konteynerın
range
konstruktörünü
kullanıyorduk
birazdan range
konstruktör'a
gelecektim
zaten
yani örneğin
şöyle
vektörün
int açılımı
arkadaşlar
ibek
efendim
tabi o zaman
küme parantezde
yoktu
e
ar
artı
tabi size
fonksiyonu da yoktu
o yoktu
bu yoktu
size of
ar
bölü
size of
yıldız ar
düşünsenize
arkadaşlar
şöyle bir
kod yazmak
zorundaydınız
tabi bu dizi
sadece bu işe
yarıyorsa
programlama
açısından da
bir felaket
durdukta duracak
ama sadece
burada
kullanılacak
derleyici
optimizasyonlarından
bahsetmiyorum
şimdi
bir konteynerı
başka bir
konteynerla
başlatmak diye
bir şey
doğrudan
söz konusu
değil
yani
örneğin
elimizde
bir
int vektör
var
ama elimizde
bir de başka
bir konteyner var
örneğin
list konteynerı
listin
int açılımı
mylist
içinde tutulan
değerler
önemli değil
ama şöyle bir şey
yazabilir miyim
vektörün
int açılımı
ifek
eşittir
mylist
hayır
bunlar
uyumlu türler
değil
yani böyle bir
dönüşüm fonksiyonu
yok
ya da
konteynerların
böyle bir
member template
konstruktörü
yok
ama
range
konstruktörü
işte bu işi
görüyor
yani örneğin
list
mylist
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
mylist
begin
and
bu template
olduğu için
konteynerdaki
öğelerin de
arkadaşlar
aynı türden
olması da
gerekmiyor
yani önemli olan
birbirine
atanabilmesi
mesela şöyle olur
muydu
vektör
double tutuyor
ama liste
int tutuyor
yine de böyle
yazabilirdim
template
olmasının
faydalarından
biri daha
o zaman bir
konteyneri başka bir
konteynerle
başlatabiliyor muyum
hayır
ama range
konstruktörü
kullanarak
bunu
yapabiliyorum
c++ 17
ve sonrası
için
citat
dediğimiz
özelliğin
önemini de
hatırlayalım
artık template
argümanını
sınıf
şablonlarında
belirli durumlarda
yazmazsam
ama dikkatli
olmamız gerekiyor
çıkarım yapılıyor
dikkat ederseniz
birçok
konuda
ben şöyle yazdım
vektör
ibek
böyle yazmanın
ve geçerli
olmasının
nedeni
c++
yani c++
öncesi
bir kotsa
c++
standarda
öncesi
bir standarda
göre derleniyorsa
bu
geçerli
olmayacak
peki
şuna
bakın
list
int
açılımı
list
my list
vektör
ibek
my list
begin
and
sadece
z
ve
for
auto
x
arkadaşlar
ibek
cout x
neden hata
ahm neden
var mı
emiren
birazdan
sorunuza
cevap vereceğim
arkadaşlar
hata
olması
nedeni
bu çok sık
yapılan bir hata
olduğu için
özellikle
göstermek
istedim
sitatla
ilgili
burada
parantez
kullandığımız
zaman
arkadaşlar
bravo
iteratör
olarak
çıkarım
yapılıyor
yani bu
vektörün
zaten
bakarsanız
göreceksiniz
bakın
vektörün
listin
int
açılımının
iteratörü
açılımı
oldu
anlaşıldı mı
evet
dolayısıyla
tür çıkarımı
burada
gördüğünüz gibi
farklı şekilde
yapıldı
şimdi
backward
compatibility
geçmişe doğru
uyumluluk
konusunda
c++
dilinin
genel
tavrı
evet
backward
compatibility
korumak
ama
çok da
radikal
değil
bu konuda
yani
resmen
mesela
şöyle
durumlar
çok da
örnek verebilirim
bir derste
isterseniz
toplu örnek
vereyim
öyle
değişiklikler
yapıldı ki
normalde
en azından
şunun
sağlanması
bekleniyor
geçmiş
konular
yeni
derleyicilerle
yeni standardı
implemente eden
derleyiciler
liderlendiğinde
A
kodun
anlamı
değişmesin
B
kodun
geçerliliği
kaybolmasın
kodun
geçerliliği
kaybolmasın
ve semantik
olarak da
bir farklılık
olmasın
ama
buna
yüzde yüz
uyulduğunu
söyleyemem
yani
eski kodların
sentaks
hatası
durumuna
düştüğü
durumlar
var
yeni
standartlarla
ve
semantik
olarak
yani
anlamsal
açıdan
kodun
anlamının
değiştiği
durumlar
var
o yüzden
özellikle
deprecated
ilan edilen
sentaks
özelliklerini
ya da
dilsel
araçları
ya da
standart
kodun
öğelerini
kullanmamakta
fayda var
evet
constructor
grubunda
copy
constructor
move
default
constructor
fill
arkadaşlar
range
constructor
ve
initialize
list
parametreli
constructor
var
özellikle
range
constructor
olması
bir
c
listindeki
değerlerle
de
bir
vektörü
ya da
bir
konteynerı
başlatabileceğiniz
anlamına
geliyor
evet
hatta
bunu söylemiştik
bakınız
modern
c++'da
global
bag'in ve
end
fonksiyonlarının
direk
eklenmesindeki
temel
motivasyonlardan
biri
bu demiştim
mesela böyle
bir dizim var
bu dizdeki
öğelerle
başlatmak
istiyorum
doğrudan
şöyle
yazabilirim
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
arkadaşlar
beg'in
a
tabası
tut
beg'in
and a
range
constructor
yine burada
devreye girecek
bu başka bir
konteyner de
olabilirdi
doğrudan bir
cdc'de
olabilirdi
arkadaşlar
özellikle
şuna dikkat
bu çok önemli
bir garanti
diyelim ki
elimizde bir
vektör var
için ne tuttuğu
önemli değil
vektörün
int açılımı
ibek
ben
vektördeki
ilk
vektörünün
adresini
kullanmak istiyorum
bunu yapmanın
birden fazla yolu var
bir kere
çenerik yolu
her zaman
data fonksiyonunu
çağırmak
arkadaşlar
data fonksiyonunu
çağırdığınız zaman
vektördeki
ilk
vektörünün
adresini
elde ediyorsunuz
bu const
olmayan
vektör için
const olmayan
adres
const vektör için
constant yıldız
olacaktı
dolayısıyla
bunu
bir cdc gibi
kullanmak için
örneğin
basit bir c
fonksiyonu
olsaydı
void
c
apis
diyoruz
print array
const
int
yıldız
d
st
size
d
orda
st
n
diyelim ki
şöyle bir
fonksiyon var
while
n-
printf
efendim
yüzde de
yıldız p
artı artı
printf
put
karş
milan
bakın
şimdi
ben
bu
vektörü
şöyle
kullanabilir
miyim
printer'e
çağırıyorum
niye bunu yapayım
o ayrı bir soru
ama herhangi bir
siyapisi için
ivek'in
datası
size'ı
burada
herhangi bir
şekilde
bir
tanımsız
davranış
bir
sentax
hatası
bir
logik
hata
hiçbir şey
yok
bunların
kontigüüs
olması
üyelerin
bellekle
ardışık olarak
tutulma garantisi
var
görüyorsunuz
değil mi
3-6-9-1-6-6
ayrıca
ilk üyenin
adresini
elde etmek
için
bakın
otop
p1
eşittir
ivek'in
datası
p1'in
türüne
bakın
int yıldız
ama şuna
bakın
henüz
görmedik
ama
burada
index
subscript
operatör
fonksiyonu
overload edilmiş
durumda
dolayısıyla
bizi
vektördeki
konteynerdeki
ilk nesneye
eriştiriyor
onun
adres
operatörüyle
adresini
alırsam
otop
p2
eşittir
yine
aslında
bizinin
ilk elemanının
adresine
ilgi etmiş
oluyorum
daha da
ilginci
begin
fonksiyonunu
çağırdım
begin
fonksiyonu
adres döndürmüyor
iteratör döndürüyor
ama iteratörü
d-referens
ettiğimde
nesneye
erişmiş
oluyorum
onun
tekrar
adres
operatörüyle
adresini
alabilirim
arkadaşlar
takip edebiliyor
muyuz
evet
hatta
izleyin
e-back
front
arkadaşlar
sequence
container'ların
ilerleyen
dakikada
aslında
string sınıfında
da göstermiş
olmalıyım
sequence
container'ların
front
isimli
fonksiyonu
container'da
tutulan
ilk
öğe'ye
back isimli
fonksiyonu
until
back
o da
container'daki
son öğe'ye
referans
döndürüyor
dolayısıyla
eğer container
boş
değilse
front
fonksiyonu
çağırırsanız
front fonksiyonu
container'daki
ilk öğe'ye
eriştirecek
demek
bu
l-value
expression
döndürdüğü
için
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
adres
operatörünün
de
operandı
yapabilirsiniz
burayı
anladık mı
ilk öğe'nin
adresini
bu şekilde
elde edebilir
container'ın
size'ında
size
fonksiyonuna
çağrı
yaparak
elde edebilirsiniz
böylece
c-pc
için
bu adresleri
ve container'da
tutulan
öğe sayısını
tamamını kullanmak
zorunda da
değilsiniz
o arada
onu da
söyleyelim
evet
peki Necati
mesela şunu
yapabilir miyim
ben
o container'daki
ilk öğe'nin
adresini
alsam
o adresi
normal bir
pointer'da
saklı
pointer aritmetiyle
yine
nesnelere
erişme
garantimi
var mı
kesinlikle
arkadaşlar
o zaman
constructor grubunu
bitirmiş olduk
initializer list
range
constructor
efendim
copy
constructor
move
size
d
constructor
size
d
one
constructor
bütün
sequence
container'larda
olan
constructor'lar
bunlar
ve default
constructor
tabi
arkadaşlar
şimdi
vektör
container'ının
via
fonksiyonlarını
önce
şöyle
benim
ide'deki
yardımcı
aracı
kullanarak
setek
tek
göstereyim
ondan sonra
tabi ki
bunları
gruplar halinde
inceleyeceğiz
herhangi bir
vektörü
nesnesi
oluşturalım
şu
nokta operatörünün
operandı
yapalım
ve
arkadaşlar
yalnız bakın
burada gördüğünüz
fonksiyonlar
c++
dahil
hariç
evet
çünkü
bazı fonksiyonlar
c++
20 ile
bazı fonksiyonlar
c++
23 ile
eklenmiş fonksiyonlar
bazı fonksiyonlar
c++
11 ile
bazı fonksiyonlar
da eski
c++
ile bile var
arkadaşlar
şöyle bakalım
append
range
stl
özellikle
container'ların
üye fonksiyonları
söz konusu
olduğu zaman
append
fiilini
sondan
ekleme
anlamında
kullanıyor
yani
append range
container'ın
sonuna
bir range'i
eklemek
için
yalnız
bir şeye
dikkat
burası
yanıltabilir
sizi
bu
c++
20 ve
23 ile
gelen
içinde
range
geçen
fonksiyonlar
benim
bugüne
kadar kullandığım
range
anlamında
değil
bu
ranges
kütüphanesindeki
range konseptiyle
ilgili
yani bu
iki tane
iteratör
kastedilmiyor
burada
gerçekten
bir range
konseptini
sağlayan
herhangi bir
öğe için
evet
assign
sequence
container'larda
hatta
container'ların
çoğunda
var
atama fonksiyonu
ama daha özel
atama operatör
fonksiyonuyla
yapamadığımız
bazı işleri
yapacak
overload'ları
var
assign
range
aynı şekilde
parametreli
ama
range
konsepti
anlamında
range
parametreli
assign
fonksiyonu
arkadaşlar
vektördeki
öğelere
erişmek için
tıpkı
string
sınıfında
olduğu gibi
hem
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
substript
operatör
fonksiyonu
hem de
at
isimli
fonksiyonu
var
stringte de
böyle
vektörde de
deckte de
böyle
ama ikisi
arasındaki
fark
index
operatör
fonksiyonunun
subscript
operatör
fonksiyonunun
benim
değişimli
köşeli
parantez
operatör
fonksiyonunun
indexin
geçerse
olması
durumunda
exception
göndermemesi
ama
at
isimli
fonksiyonun
exception
göndermesi
sequence
containerların
back
fonksiyonu
hepsini göstereceğiz
containerdaki
son üyeye
erişim
sağlıyor
içinde
begin
ve
end
geçen
bütün
fonksiyonlar
iteratör
veren
fonksiyonlar
kapasite
kapasiteyi
get eden
fonksiyon
c
begin
end
clear
array hariç
bütün
containerlarda
var
containerdaki
bütün
üyeleri
silen
fonksiyon
yani
erase
all
anlamında
clear
cr
begin
crn
data
arkadaşlar
ilk öğenin
adresini
yani
o
allocate edilen
bellek bloğunun
adresi aynı zamanda
ama
nesne adresi
olarak da
dizinin
ilk elemanının
adresini
döndürüyor
emplace
insert
anlamında
ama
insertten
farklı olarak
bütün
containerler için
geçerli
az önce
söylediğim gibi
üveyi
oluşturacak
constructora
gönderilecek
argümanları
alıp
onları
perfect forward
ederek
containerdaki
nesneyi
oluşturuyor
dolayısıyla
a
variadic
fonksiyon
çünkü
constructorın
n tane
parametresi
olabilir
b
perfect forwardingden
faydalanıyor
yani
universal
reference
parametreli
bariyedik
parametre
paketine
sahip
emplace
back
sondan
ekleyerek
öğeyi
oluşturacak
empty
is empty
anlamında
arkadaşlar
efendim
and
iteratör
veriyor
erase
algoritmalarda
bir örneğini
görmüştük
containerların
iki tane
erase
fonksiyonu var
biri
bir iteratör
konumunu alıp
o iteratör
konumundaki
öğeyi
silen
diğeri ise
iki tane
iteratör alıp
o range'deki
öğeyleri silen
front
ilk öğeye
referans döndürüyor
get allocator
adı üstünde
vektörün
kullandığı
allocator'ı
get ediyor
derken
geri dönüş
değeriyle
iletiyor
insert
fonksiyonu
verilen bir konuma
yeni bir öğe
ekliyor
insert
range
verilen bir
konuma
bir range'e
ekliyor
max
size
kontennerda
tutulabilecek
maksimum
öğe sayısını
döndürüyor
atom
operatör
fonksiyonu
hem
special
member
fonksiyonu
olan var
yani
copy
assignment
move
hem de
initializer
list
parametreli
arkadaşlar
operatör
atama
fonksiyonu
var
köşeli parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
kontennerdaki
öğeyi erişmek
için
popback
son öğeyi
silmek
için
pushback
sondan
ekleme
yapmak
için
reback'in
veren
reverse
iteratör
veren
fonksiyonlar
reserve
kapasiteyi
rezerve
eden
fonksiyon
ki
çok
önemli
resize
konteynerın
size'ını
değiştiren
fonksiyon
bu
size'ı
değiştirmesi
demek
size'ı
arttırabilmesi
ya da
düşürebilmesi
demek
dolayısıyla
ilginç
bir şekilde
resize
konteynerı
öğe
eklemek
için de
konteynerdan
öğe
silmek
için de
sequence
konteynerlarda
çağırabileceğimiz
bir fonksiyon
shrink
to fit
çok önemli
ekses
fazladan
kullanılmayan
kapasiteyi
geri vermek
için
çağıracağımız
fonksiyon
size
konteynerdaki
öğe sayısını
döndüren
swap
iki konteynerı
swap eden
fonksiyon
ona da bir
hemen çok
kısacıklama
yapalım
arkadaşlar
konteynerların
hem kendi
swap fonksiyonları
var
hem de
jenerik
swap
fonksiyonuyla
konteynerları
swap
edebilirsiniz
ve bir
şey dikkat edelim
ister
jenerik
swap
specialization
olsun
ister
konteynerın
kendi
swap
fonksiyonu
olsun
konteynerın
implementasyonundaki
pointerları
kullanarak
swap
yapıyor
yani
örneğin
şöyle iki
tane
arkadaşlar
konteyner
olsaydı
vektörün
string
açılımı
vek
vektörün
string
açılımı
vek
şimdi
birinci
vektörde
10 bin
tane
string
ikinci
vektörde
10 bin
tane
string
tutuluyor
olsaydı
ben
vek
1'in
swap
fonksiyonunu
bu şekilde
çağırdığımda
ya da
jenerik
swap
fonksiyonunu
yani
stud
swap'ı
böyle
çağırdığımda
vektörün
içindeki
stringler
swap
edilecek
mi
yani
kopyalanacak
mı
örneğin
cevap
hayır
tipik olarak
bir vektör
implementasyonu
içinde
pointerlar
tutuyor
ya
ona da
değinmiştik
o pointerlar
swap
ediliyor
yani
swap'ın
parmaşıklığı
o1 mi
bir
bonodasyonda
o n
mi
o1
anlaşıldı
değil mi
buna
dikkat
tamam efendim
gelelim
şimdi
son
fonksiyonlarımıza
onların hepsini
ayrı ayrı
göreceğiz
evet
dedik ki
swap
hem
global fonksiyon
olarak var
hem de
üye fonksiyon
var
böylece
bitirmiş
olduk
bitirmiş olduk
derken bunları
tek tek
göreceğiz
yani en azından
ne var
ne yok
görmüş
olduk
arkadaşlar
şimdi bir
hem özelde bir
konteynerı
hem de
hem genel olarak bir
konteynerı
hem de
bir vektörü
dolaşmanın
traverse etmenin
yani
bütün elemanları
ziyaret etmenin
bütün elemanlara
erişmenin
yollarından
başlayacağız
önce
herhangi bir elemana
erişmek için
hangi yollar var
onları görelim
yani
konteynerda tutulan
öğe'ye
erişmek için
referans semantiğiyle
arkadaşlar
vektörün
string açılımı
aspect
doğrudan
initializer list
konstruktörü
kullanalım
Ayşe
Necati
İlker
Azmi
Atman
şimdi bir
bir kere
elimizde bir
iteratörün
bir iteratör varsa
bir öğenin
konumu varsa
o iteratörü
dereferans ederek
vektördeki
öğeye
erişebiliriz
örneğin
auto iter
eşittir
esvek
begin
arkadaşlar
fiyat
yıldız
iter
tabi bu
iteratör
konst iteratör olabilir
reverse iteratör olabilir
ama sonuçta
iteratörler
direferansı
örneğin
vektördeki
ilk öğeye
erişmiş oldum
mesela
bu iteratör
konumu
değil de
iki sonraki
konumu elde etmek için
iter
artı iki
gibi bir ifade
kullanıp
onu
bir
referans
edebilirdim
ya da
çenerik bir kod için
next fonksiyonunu
kullanabilirdim
next
iter
default argümanı
hatırlayın
default argüman
1 oluyordu
ya da
next iter
yani bir iteratör varsa
elimde
o iteratörü
direferans ederek
o konumdaki
öğeye erişebilirim
bu bütün
konteynerlar için
geçerli
ama dikkat
sakın
end iteratörünü
direferans etmeyin
yani örneğin
böyle bir
iteratör varsa
yıldız iter
tanımsız
davranış
ama
mesela şunda bir
problem yok
yıldız
iter
eksi
bir
ya da
yıldız
arkadaşlar
studprev
iter
böylece sonu
ve yerleşmiş olurum
sequence
container'ların
front ve back
fonksiyonlarına
çağrı yaparak
yine
container'daki
ilk öğeyi
ve son öğeyi
erişebilirim
custom
bir type
kullanıyoruz
diyelim
örneğin
cv
mat
bu durumda
neler
söyleyebiliriz
ne açıdan
soruyu
sorduğunuza
bağlı
örneğin
default
constructor
yoksa
efendim
fill
constructor
doğrudan
kullanamazsınız
gibi
ama
onun dışında
bir custom
type
olmasıyla
custom type
olmaması
arasında
herhangi bir şekilde
bir fark yok
yani
container'da
custom type
tutulması
son derece
sık karşımıza
çıkan bir durum
ki ben örneklerin
çoğunda
emiran
örneğin
vektörde
date
tutacağım
şu anda
elimizde
custom type
ne varsa
onları da
örneklerde
sık sık
kullanacağım
evet
belki
custom type
ile ilgili
sadece şunu
söyleyebilirim
bu aşamada
o da
taşıma
semantiği
ile ilgili
arkadaşlar
şimdi
C++'ın
standart
kütüphanesinin
türleri
moved
from
state
teki
objeleri
valid
ama
değeri
herhangi bir
değer olabilir
garantisini
veriyor
yani
moved
from
state
teki
bir nesne
invariantları
bozulmamış
valid
state
ama
custom
type'lar
bu garantiyi
vermeyebilir
ideali
custom
type'ların da
bu garantiyi
vermesi
ama
dokümentasyonu
okumadan
custom
type'ların
bu
moved
from
state'deki
verdiği
garantileri
sanki
STL'deki
türler gibi
aynı
garantiyi
verdiğini
düşünmeyin
belki
custom
type'larla
ilgili
konteynerlarda
tutulması
ile ilgili
söyleyebileceğim
ilk
cümle
bu
dikkat etmek
gerekir
evet
arkadaşlar
iki
belirli
konteynerler
custom
type'ların
operatör
overloadinglerinden
faydalanıyor
örneğin
set
konteynerında
default
template
argümanı
ile birlikte
tutabilmemiz
için
custom
type'ın
less than
comparable
olması
gerekiyor
yani
küçüktür
operatörü
ile
karşılaştırılabilir
olması
gerekiyor
zaten
c++
standardı
konteynerda
tutulacak
öğelerin
hangi
koşulları
sağlaması
gerektiğini
onu da
belirtiyor
tabi bu
c++
20 ile
artık
konseptleri de
bu konuda
doğrudan
kullanabiliyoruz
peki
o zaman
front ve back
fonksiyonlarından
bahsedelim
ama dikkat
front ve back
fonksiyonlarını
boş
konteyner için
çağırırsanız
yine
exception
throw etmediğini
tanımsız
davranış
olduğunu
söyleyebiliriz
dolayısıyla
örneğin
aspect
front
arkadaşlar
doğrudan
elveri olarak da
kullanabilirsiniz
örneğin
artı eşit
nas
aspect
and
back
özür dilerim
efendim
artı eşit
gül
ölçe
vektördeki
ilk öğeyi
ayşe
nas
son öğeyi
artma gül
yapmış olduk
vektördeki
öğeleri
yazdıralım
şimdilik
jprint fonksiyonuyla
aspect
değerlerinin
değiştiğini
göreceksiniz
arkadaşlar
öğeye erişmek
için
vektör
string
dekül
sınıflarının
ve
array
sınıflarının
indeks
operatör
fonksiyonu
var
dolayısıyla
şöyle bir
döngüyle
örneğin
size
t
i
eşit
sıfır
i
küçük
svek'in
size
artı
i
svek
köşeli
parantezi
i
indeksindeki
öğeye
erişmiş
oluyoruz
yine
referans
semantiği
yani örneğin
arkadaşlar
buna
yine
artı eşit
operatörün
operanda yapıp
hepsinin
sonuna
can
ekleyebilirdim
yalnız
burada
indeksin
geçersiz
olması
durumunda
exception
throw
etmiyor
dolayısıyla
safe
bir kod
yazmak
istiyorsanız
mutlaka
indeksin
geçerli
olduğuna
emin
olmalısınız
exception
prove etmemesi
demek
undefined
behavior
demek
arkadaşlar
zaten
bakın
safe
coding
artık
şöyle
tanımlıyorlar
modern
tanımı
şu
c++
safe
coding
in
c++
ya da
safe
code
in
c++
hiçbir
tanımsız
davranış
ovesi
barındırmayan
kod
en az
bir tane
tanımsız
davranış
varsa
o
safe
kod
değil
köşeli parantez
operatör
fonksiyonu
tabii ki
öğeler
bellekte
kontigüüs
olduğu için
index
ile erişim
constant
time'da
arkadaşlar
mesela
şöyle bir
kod
yazsaydım
cout
index
girin
in
idx
size t
cout
svec
idx
exception
göndermeyecek
index
girin
dört
fatma
ki
son öre
efendim
sıfır
ayşe
yirmi
üç
tanımsız
davranış
ama
aynı amaç
için
add
fonksiyonunu
çağırırsam
aspect
add
arkadaşlar
idx
şimdi artık
indexin
geçerse
olması
durumunda
exception
throw
ve check
it
then
exception
out of range
sınıfı
türünden
hatırlayalım
out of range
logic error
sınıfından
sınıfı
da
doğrudan
stood exception
kalıtım
yoluyla
elde edilmiş
evet
index
girin
üç
azmi
index
girin
dokuz
exception
cut
invalid
vector
subscript
evet
çarşamba günü
devam edeceğiz
vektör sınıfını
bitirmeye çalışacağım
zaten vektör sınıfını
bitirdiğimiz zaman
diğer
sequence
konteynerler
daha az zamanımız
olacak
derse katıldığınız için
teşekkür ediyorum
çarşamba günü
görüşmek üzere
herkese
iyi akşamlar
diliyorum
hoşçakalın
değerli arkadaşlar
abone ol